e
e e
uh let's see how we get started this um
this as as some of you might know that
uh technically uh the science and
technology has our committee room for
Tuesdays uh and but I like to oh Bob you
got a
new so um this this actually this room
it brings back kind of fun memory
because the original Commerce Committee
was 207 the room Bo hello so the same
views of the window same same cozy space
this is brings back memories from me um
but having said that um I would say that
um we will still continue the policy of
the commerence committee that every
every bill will have a subcommittee will
go to subcommittee so as you can see
today these are liquor bills these will
be liquor subcommittee and um given that
there's going to be a flux of bills
coming in and little transition uh next
week I think we'll just schedule the
subcommittee uh for these two bills next
week it will not be on a Tuesday because
I will be in Pittsburgh and some people
will be in Washington doing what cannot
imagine okay so we'll open up the public
hearing on house spill 242 relative to
brew pub licenses oh this is my
bill uh Scott why don't you come up and
explain what what this bills
about good morning for the record my
name is Scott Shire I work for the New
Hampshire beer distributors Association
and uh I'd be happy to sort of give a
recap would you like the short version
or the long
version why don't you give the whole
story and that way we can okay okay so
essentially um for those of you who have
been here before you understand the
basics of the three- tier system and for
those of you who don't I'll give you the
real quick primer um following the
repeal of prohibition the federal
government gave States their rights to
regulate alcohol in the way that they
see fit and uh in Most states there was
a three- tier system developed
wherein suppliers had separation from
Distributors and retailers so that they
wouldn't have somebody monopolizing the
market for instance uh back in the days
before prohibition somebody large like a
Schlitz for example might own their own
bars and also do their own distribution
wherein they could take their products
and sell them for cheap and drive
competitors out of the marketplace and
in the process you know encourage
intoxication Etc while um some people
might have been fans of that most people
weren't and following prohibition the
three-tier system was set up so there's
a separation between a producer or a
brewer in this case or a Venter um a
Wholesale Distributor or a broker and
then a retailer with the exception here
in New Hampshire of the State Liquor
Commission who acts as both the
distributor and the retailer so there
there is as representative hunt likes to
say one huge uh you know exception in
the in the state of New Hampshire to the
three- tier system there are also some
other smaller exceptions um small
Brewers are allowed to self-distribute
up to 00 barrels um and then Wineries
and distilleries also have similar
restrictions um on their distribution
volumetric restrictions so anyway this
this bill in particular came up because
there was
one restaurant lensey who wanted to open
a brewery but they had common ownership
with other restaurants already and
that's a Prohibition of three- tier you
can't have cross tier ownership so this
particular Restaurant Group had half a
dozen to 10 other restaurants already
they bought a facility that had a
brewing uh previously had brewing in
there and decided they wanted to brew
they couldn't do it they looked at
several different options and then they
went to the Liquor Commission and came
up with this potential fix for it um
everything was uh was sort of in
agreement with the industry after some
wrangling and uh in a couple of hearings
last year we agreed on language and
unfortunately at the end of the session
there was a clerical error and uh the
wrong language was adopted and passed so
we're here to basically adopt the right
language and correct what happened at
the end of last session what did I leave
out I like your phraseology and maybe
you should we'll hear the other side
their testimony to sure but otherwise
you are in support of the bill as we are
in support of the bill as presented yes
great thank you very much any questions
from the committee
members see none thank
you so
sorry good morning Mr chairman members
of the committee for the record my name
is Mike Summers I'm the president CEO of
the New Hampshire lodging and Restaurant
Association uh we worked closely with
Scott shy and his group uh in the last
legislative session uh he referenced a
clerical error uh I think this cleans up
the clerical error um but we are in
support of the bill um and have no
issues with
it happy to answer questions perfect
thank you very much any questions to the
committee seeing none thank you and does
the Liquor Commission want to say
anything about this
bill that noisy fan
yes that's why this building is
condemned and we're all leaving here at
the end of the
session thank you chairman and committee
members uh Lieutenant Matt Culver from
New Hampshire Liquor Commission division
of enforcement
uh thank you Mr chairman it's always
nice to have some comedy relief right um
amongst all the good work we do in this
committee um Mark armaganian chief of
liquor enforcement
licensing um Matt Matt will uh talk
about some of the technical notes in
this but I think uh for those of us that
were here last uh last session
um my two predecessors here um have
testified both Scott Mike um very
eloquently on on what transposed um we
we are in the same position as everybody
else this fixes a a clerical error um
that uh at the time Senator Bradley was
trying to fix uh before he retired so um
with that in mind I'll I'll give the
microphone over to uh
Matt thank you very much um
the the popup license uh is a license
that requires not only has the
manufacturing but it also requires a on
premise restaurant it's one of the only
manufacturing licenses that does that so
the whole consideration of the croser
system was done specifically in the Brew
Pub license this doesn't apply to the
other manufacturing licenses Only The
Brew Pub the fix in House Bill 242 is
simply focused around the distribution
the distribution of that Brew Pub
manufacturing their own beverage and
distributing it to now their their um
authorized on or off premise licenses
their own
licenses um and it limits that to the
quantity stated before the 200 uh 2500
barrels and it only um allows them to
self-distribute to one of those
licenses otherwise they have to go
through the Wholesale Distributors add
different tier in the
system any questions from the committee
members I just realized we only have one
new member
here but do you know some of your new
ntion members are they do they let you
know they're coming or do they yeah okay
because I was kind of hoping this would
be
educational but uh but
uh obviously from the old all the other
older members of the committee know they
know what's going on and the new member
he's just getting up to speed here
so thank you very much you okay so uh
for the for the take-home uh
representative pressent is that uh brew
pubs is uh are an outlier of
lenses to all our other liquor
lenses uh and they uh as Mr sh pointed
out um they they trample on the three
here not just slightly but
overwhelmingly trample on it uh and I
will make sure you know this because all
the other committee this passed before I
got here as much as people like to talk
that how long I've been here I did not
have anything to do with the uh Brew Pub
lure but uh it did get p and it is
something that we we deal
with with that I will close the public
hearing on house Bell 242
and since I only scheduled 15 minutes
we're ready for the next one uh open up
the public hearing and House Bill 81
allowing patrons to take purchased
alcohol beverages into the restroom of a
restaurant
and uh I don't think we've ever we I
don't think we've ever we've had this
conversation before so representative
sullon will fill out a pin card later I
sure
will um hello everybody most people here
know me I guess I don't think I've told
me that you yet um okay yeah so this
bill is pretty simple right now it's
illegal to take your beverage with you
into a restroom if you're at a bar or
restaurant and while it seems like kind
of a trivial thing not a big deal I
don't know exactly what the reasoning is
I've been told it was probably to keep
underage people from getting alcohol um
handoffs in the bathroom I I think it's
important that we allow people to be in
charge of their drinks at all times and
so this the motivation of this comes
from a pretty heavy story where a an
incredibly close friend of mine uh one
of my one of my best
friends one of my one of my best friends
uh one of my really close friends was um
ruied rufi in a bar and woke up in a in
a hotel room that wasn't there as
clearly had been raped and to me it just
seems like you know when I was in
college there was a problem with
people's drinks being drugged at at uh
fat houses and there was a big campaign
at my my callers saying always be in
charge of your your own drink always be
in control of your alcohol that sort of
stuff and this runs counter to that I
didn't really I learned about this law
from working on this committee um and I
think actually representative Hunt is
the one who who told me about this at
one point and um and I didn't really
think too much about it and because i'
never actually heard anybody enforcing
it or anything like that but then I did
see in Manchester a bar was out over the
summer that actually had a had a a sign
on the door saying you're not allowed to
bring your your alcoholic beverage into
the bathroom and so to me it just seems
like common sense that if we don't want
people to potentially um you know
particularly if they're a little under
the influence they just bought a drink
they have to go use the restroom they
put it down and that opens up the
opportunity to for something something
bad had to happen and um and then just
from talking to this I you know just
very recently I was talking about this
bill that I'm going to be testifying on
today and a family member told me that
that uh she was she was roofied in in a
bar um probably 15 years ago which I had
no idea about until just talking about
this so these things happen and we
people should be in charge of their own
drinks and we don't want to make it an
opportunity easier for somebody to
potentially uh take advantage of
somebody who is
um putting their drink down to abide by
a law and uh so that's uh that's the
motivation behind it so take any
questions if you want
it so you you do know that the reason
why the law was passed in the first
place is because people were taking
drinks into the bathrooms and spiking
them yes that I was told that it could
be that or or the fear of that or the
fear of uh handing them off to underage
people correct but yeah I I I was told I
think you and I think somebody else told
me that the motivation behind it was to
get uh or to take away the ability to
you know buy a a vodka soda and then add
more vodka to it or whatever um I mean I
would I would think that that that's
possible I I'm I'm more concerned about
somebody waking up in a hotel room after
being raped which is what happened to my
close
friend right I I hope the person who did
it get was found out and prosecuted nope
uh they woke up in an empty hotel room
that wasn't theirs and don't
know never found out who the who the who
the as salent was did this occur in New
Hampshire no it did not occur in New
Hampshire
okay because most hotels have cameras
and they would see who's coming into
this was this was like 20 years ago yeah
okay
so uh any other questions from the
committee members yes we have to hit
your button
so my question is uh who is responsible
if the drink is taken to the restroom
and they do something the hotel is
responsible for that or because that's
not under the supervision of the any of
the staff of the hotel
restaurant so your question is if
somebody were to take a a beverage into
the bathroom and
then yeah they do something on their own
I mean that would be on on on them I
would how we prove
that no no be be careful when you do
that so you're you you're asking a
question and then you let him response
okay sorry and then you look to me and
say further question thank you I'm
learning okay I know I realized this
your first day with representative hun
yeah that's fine
um yeah I mean I would
say who who would be responsible now I
mean there there's a law now how would
you how would you prove that right like
so if if you are
taking if you if the fear is that I'm
coming in with a little bottle of vodka
in my pocket and I'm going to bring it
into the bathroom and add it to drinks I
could also drink that in the bathroom as
well like if if somebody's going to do
that then there's really no way to truly
monitor that um I think the way that the
restaurant would be potentially
responsible as if the person was clearly
very intoxicated and they continued to
sell them drinks but um I don't think if
they sold them one drink and that person
was you know milking that drink and keep
eating adding their own I there's
evidence that they only sold them one
drink I think that that would should be
able to protect the the bar owner
because they would say hey we we only
sold them one drink so something else
happened they either were drinking
illegally in the bathroom or somewhere
else with alcohol they didn't purchase
from us or they um were leaving and
coming back like whatever the reasons
are um so I I I think we we know we know
that the the responsibility is on the
bartender and the establishment to not
overs serve people if they only served
one drink then presumably they should be
able to kind of prove that they have
receipts from what they sold
okay right I I my I assume the question
is is in terms of whatever act that was
committed inside let's say you've given
it to a minor right or giving having a
spike in the drink it got so spiked to
the point where they were became intoxic
ated now the onus is on the
restaurant because if that person walks
out and the liquor enforcement sees that
person and the person I assume will deny
they did anything in the bathroom of
course and so therefore now the
restaurant is
liable for uh that person being drunk
right and I think that's what he's going
with that question I got his I got his
intent and I think that I think I just
answered it I mean if if The Liquor
Commission would come and I'm sure
they'll speak after me and they can
explain what their their process to
investigate this would be but presumably
they would look at it and say well
there's no evidence that that they
actually over served him they served him
one alcoholic beverage or two alcoholic
beverages if they had you know if you
show up and if I show up at a bar and
they show they serve me 10 and then I do
something then they're going to find
that out but I mean if if he's been
served one or two
drinks and somehow is so drunk that you
know there's there's a serious problem
presumably the El commission would be
able to kind of figure that out by
looking at receipts and I mean I know
there's an investigation right
there
okay yep representative
pelli yes thank you for taking my
question so would the um uh restaurant
or the uh establishment owner have the
ability to not enforce this policy is it
voluntary so I could see a lot of issues
where the restaurant owner would say you
know there's cleanliness issues there's
um you know I don't I can't monitor
anything you know it's not enforcable so
would the restaurant owner be able to
say I'm I'm not going to um allow this
policy thank you sure yeah of course no
this is not forcing them to say You must
allow everybody to take their alcoholic
beverages into the bathroom if they
don't want to do that then they have a
right to set their own policies I'm just
trying to enable restaurants
to not put up signs up there if they
don't want to um to allow people to make
that allow the The Establishment to make
their own choices um but yeah this is
not requiring them to allow people to
take whatever they want into the
bathroom that that's they want to make
their own policy they can but right now
the policy is that you can't and I want
to allow restaurants to not have to have
that policy by
law so it's enabling for the
establishment
representative
Herbert I'm I'm under the impression
it's not legal to go into the bathroom
with right that is currently legal
that's the current so you you can't do
this right and so I'm trying to this
bill would allow that to become
legal I'm sorry I get it right sharesa
uh maybe I missed uh the beginning part
of it uh what and so you might have
rrate what what's the advantage of uh
allowing in in the room yeah it's not
necess an advantage of having it in
there I mean it's just I think when you
are when you when you have an alcoholic
beverage you should be in control of
that alcoholic beverage at all time and
so if you're somebody who's at the
restaurant and or the bar and you buy a
drink and then you need to use a
restroom if you you can't take it with
you then it it it it gives an
opportunity for somebody to take
advantage and and Spike the drink with a
drug and so I don't know if you heard
the story but I have a very close friend
who woke up after having only one drink
at at a bar and woke up in a in a hotel
room and had clearly been raped and
there was nobody in there and so um that
was the motivation behind this when I
discovered that this was the current
state of the law I just think that you
should be in charge of your own beverage
at all times to try to minimize chances
of things like that happening
you mean somebody can put something so
this is the part where you turn to me
okay and say I have a further question
so I have follow question yes you may
proceed so is the liability of the
restaurant same if the drink is being
done in the in the restaurant versus in
the
restroom the liability yeah uh I mean I
don't think that there's I think I think
the the reason the law is it is
currently in place is because they were
a fearful of people buying a drink and
then adding more alcohol to it and so my
my my solution to that would be or not
solution but my explanation how they
would deal with that is if there was
some sort of a concern that somebody was
over served there would be an
investigation as there always is by The
Liquor Commission if there's an issue
and they would see that they either were
overs served or they weren't over served
uh you know if you only bought one drink
and you were drunk enough that looked
like you had 10 drinks then that's
that's obviously not on the restaurant
something else else was going on um we
also know
that I don't know how effective this
policy is at preventing that I mean I
have spoken to several restaurant and
bar owners in the state who have told me
that every night they find nips in the
trash of bathroom so I mean you know
they're either drinking them or they're
you know I just think it you know it
probably isn't it probably isn't
effective at achieving that goal as is
but I don't think the liability would
suddenly shift to the the restaurant
because I think you know just because
you leave someplace drunk there's going
to be an investigation if something
happened and the Liquor Commission is
capable of of doing a thorough
investigation and looking at how many
drinks were served or whatever to make
sure that they hadn't broken the
law great one one last follow uh we
don't let too many but uh we'll let you
have one more but if it's a quickie
right yeah quick so I feel that if they
take the drink in the back B they can
also misused by they can put the drug
now see that is I'm glad you did that
because that's what you cannot say
because you're saying I think okay so
what we do we have a policy is that if
you were going to go down this pipe you
would say would you believe okay okay
would you believe that I think okay but
in general the purpose of these hearings
is just to gather information we're not
into an interrog ation you'll have
plenty of time to tell us what you think
when we get into the full committee and
the subcommittee work but but in the
hearing we generally don't want to hear
what you think okay thank
you okay representative pusc thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for your
testimony representative uh thank you
for taking my question uh case in point
if somebody bought a soft drink at the
establishment and took it into the
bathroom and took their little nip of
vodka threw it into the drink th threw
it into the can or or glass of soda uh
would
this uh Bill have any ramification with
that I mean presumably not it's already
illegal to consume alcoholic beverages
that are not bought at that
establishment in the establishment so
somebody's breaking the law in that case
and that seems like since you're allowed
I don't think there's any prohibition on
bringing a a Coke or Pepsi into the
bathroom and then spiking it with I
Don't Know Jack Daniels or whatever um
you know I mean if somebody's going to
try to do it they're going to they're
going to be able to do that so I think I
think the while I understand the intent
of the current prohibition on this I
don't think that it's actually all that
effective because you just found you
just laid out a really easy way that I
could have nip in my pocket and Spike a
a Coke that I just bought and there's no
prohibition of bringing that coke in
there because technically it was sold
without alcohol um somebody can correct
me if I'm wrong that you can't bring any
drinks in into the into into restrooms
but I don't think that that is the law
and so you cannot bring any alcohol into
an alcohol license establishment right
so if you're going to break the law and
bring alcohol into an alcoholics that
you bought somewhere else into the
establishment then this prohibition I
doubt is going to prevent somebody from
from spiking or whatever where fearful
of
happening thank you very much all right
thanks I seemingly have no pink cards
here so I assume there might be people
have opinions ah okay so this is another
rookie mistake right when you see those
pink cards you want to make sure you get
rid of
them this is good this is a good
orientation this is good have to
remember this when we doing orientation
this is great okay whatever that is okay
uh yeah so Mike
iume which one which Bill are we doing
71 yes right come
on good morning Mr chairman members of
the committee for the rec again for the
record my name is Mike Summers president
CEO of the New Hampshire lodging and
Restaurant Association um we have a
great deal of concern with this proposal
um for all the issues that you really
just kind of baned around um obviously
um I respectfully disagree that I think
that by allowing uh alcoholic beverages
to be taken into the bath bathroom on
top of the illicit things that are
happening I think really does raise the
liability for the restaurant owner or
the lensey regardless of the of the type
of license but for the lense so um and
and really the biggest concern I think
for us is whilst certainly U uh can
acknowledge that we have heard and seen
instances where yes restaurants are
finding nips in the trash cans Etc um
again that's against the best efforts of
what the business owners are trying to
prevent but where we get quite concerned
is the underage consumption in bathrooms
you know when we when we're monitoring
our service area you know restaurant
floor Hotel restaurant whatever it might
be you know we have staff that is coming
and going at all times that's not
happening necessarily in a bathroom
unless we post somebody in a bathroom
and frankly uh this is where we could
see the intersection of uh of AG
individuals purchasing alcohol and
meeting up with their underage friends
in a stall and just passing the drinks
off kind of scenario and I think that's
where we have a great deal of concern um
you know certainly can appreciate the
the horrific story that you know
triggered this uh proposal but um you
know I think this is where um businesses
working with with customers you know
hopefully trying to find ways that we
can combat these kinds of issues I will
also say that in talking with
enforcement and uh I assume they're
going to testify but you know more and
more businesses have cameras in their uh
service areas now for the very reason of
liability right because what we're
trying to mitigate is the liability so
if we know for a fact that an individual
is slipping drinks to an underage person
in the restaurant we can catch them at
it um you know if they're doing it
surreptitiously if it's in a bathroom
where there's no cameras there's no
proof there's no way to track it just
creates an issue for us um so I I think
the bottom line is we have a great deal
of concern with this we hope we don't
change this particular proposal um so
with that I'm happy to try to answer any
questions you may
have great any questions from the
committee
members I guess look easy thank
you
okay uh Chief
armagan and Danielle
Elis deputy chief chair to okay okay
there's good
good morning for the record my name is
Danielle Elon I am uh the deputy chief
of uh New Hampshire Liquor enforcement
and Licensing nice to meet you you new
members you'll be seeing a lot of our
our group today um I just wanted to
clarify a couple things um so everybody
has a clear understanding of what the
current law is what the current
investigation process is and um what the
law would do so yes the law right now
prohibits drinks from being brought into
the restroom um to speak to the over
server and minor issue uh an over if an
over service occurs there is a very
detailed and thorough investigation that
is conducted um so if we do encounter an
intoxicated person on the premise we do
do a full investigation we pull receipts
we interview staff we pull surveillance
video if that's the case so there could
be a situation where someone does um add
alcohol to their beverage in the
restaurant or in the bathroom and the
restaurant is not held liable if they
did not serve and were properly
monitoring the premise however um there
is statute that does say if a person
under the age of 21 is caught in
possession of alcohol inside your
licensed establishments then you are
liable as the leny that's very clear
that's a very black and white law if
they possess or consume alcohol on your
premise you're liable doesn't matter how
they they obtained it doesn't matter how
they got it um the state is is very
strict when it comes to to minors
possessing alcohol um in terms of lenses
business practices um as the state and
liquor enforcement we're not in the
business of telling the leny how to run
their establishment um they we inform
them of the laws it is up to them to
determine how they would like to uh
staff their establishments or the
individual business practices that they
put in place so to answer some of those
questions questions the leny could still
prohibit drinks in the bathroom they
would still be authorized to do that
they can prohibit drinks anywhere in
their license establishments that they
don't want uh people to drink the law
requires us to have approved Pro areas
of service which are the areas that they
say am I able to serve drinks in this
room or in this function hall or in this
um you know smaller room but they are
also allowed to limit it and create any
business practices that they think will
benefit them in uh safely operating
their business and in compliance with
the laws so they still would be able to
restrict access to the bathroom to um
you know follow up with what Mike summer
said um Staffing they're unable to staff
it they're unable to monitor it they
would still be able to to prohibit that
access if they if they wish
to Great any questions from the
committee
members yes represent wsh thank you Mr
chairman do you feel that there could
possibly be you know Under reporting
possibly a lot of Under
reporting um of the situation that
representative suan U mentioned because
just because of the you know
embarrassment and having to go through
the legal system so that you know
perhaps we don't know how large a
problem that this could possibly be and
that this could definitely help to avoid
it sure I think it it's hard to say one
way or the other what I would say is
that those complaints wouldn't
necessarily come to our organization um
they could come to us if there was if it
was suspected that um you know a
bartender or staff member was the one um
spiking the drinks but those complaints
tend to go more towards the local police
department so it's hard for us to say
that one way or another because it
wouldn't necessarily be um a complaint
that we would receive
directly any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your
testimony
um okay so that's you guys I got no
other cards we're all
set uh K fry from new Futures is support
of the
bill and Elizabeth Sergeant New
Hampshire Association of chiefs of
police for opposed to the bill and with
that we'll close the public hearing on
House Bill
81 and we got four minutes
okay
when
e
e e
uh so we have a minute before before we
start and uh um we have representative
Speer was complaining about the
ventilation system being so noisy here
so I will take this opportunity to uh
officially announce because not everyone
is knows that that we uh will be
abandoning this
building come to the we are we're going
to go up into the woods
up it's going to be a Scenic Drive to
get to where we're going uh but
uh would so uh but we'll be here in
conquer and um and but that will that
will I I assume it's supposed to happen
this this spring so I assume it'll
probably when we start in September
doing our our subcommittee or whatever
retain bills we will be meeting don't
know where we're going they do oh yeah
it's it's called what's the building
called anybody anybody help me out here
what's the building conquered that we're
all going to it used to be the insurance
company's building the prison it's very
close to the prison you drive by it they
get
there who's from conquered here somebody
must know the answer to this
question the Department of Justice there
but after they got vacated this building
they moved up there but what what was
was that conquered insurance or what was
the insurance company that used to be in
that I see someone from the banking
Department right
Lincoln Lincoln yes that's what it was
Lincoln so so anyway uh they going knock
this building down no they're going to
rip this whole V they're going to re God
Ren the whole building the ventilation
system but evidently it's so dramatic in
terms of tearing and making a mess that
that they're going to we're going to uh
go on vacation another
Co trip okay all right 104 45 let's open
up the public hearing on uh House Bill
77 providing businesses from scanning
individuals licenses when selling
alcohol or tobacco products and I see
the prime sponsor here
represent good morning
representative Mr
chairman good morning uh Mr chairman
honorable members of the the committee
for the record uh I am representative
Kevin verell from inham 2 I represent uh
Auburn Candia and Deerfield um this bill
is a direct result of um a constituent
request and so
um unfortunately my constituent has the
bad habit of um smoking uh smoking
cigarettes and
so and other people have reached out as
well so when they go to purchase
cigarettes at C certain
establishments The Establishment is not
just checking the
identification for age
verification but they are scanning that
that identification typically a driver's
license and that gives uh many of my
constituents pause for privacy
concerns so we
can we can imagine
sort of a negative
scenario where we have somebody working
at an
establishment convenience
store and a customer comes in that
perhaps they're interested in perhaps
they they dislike and so they check the
identification and they scan it into the
database and now later of course that is
searchable so now you have the full name
you have the home address the driver's
license number you have a lot of
personal
information being
stored and for the life of me and and
maybe somebody can inform me for the
life of me I I can't
imagine why a business selling tobacco
products or alcohol would need to scan
and save personal
identification information
if we dismiss that as a concern which
you know I suppose you
could we can imagine people's personal
information being stored on a computer
that's attached to the internet and the
store gets hacked and now all that
personal
information is is stolen and and now you
know available to whoever whoever did
the
hacking this bill is actually paired
down from uh what I initially wanted to
file I wanted to file a ban on scanning
identification of somebody purchasing
any any good or service that they have a
legal right uh to to to purchase right
you check the ID maybe you write down
the driver's license number right that's
what we do in some in some cases if you
go to purchase a firearm they don't scan
your driver's license they they notice
it's a New Hampshire driver's license
and they put the the driver license
number and and they have that that
information in a a secured state and
federal database this is this is
different so this is a this is a good
faith effort to protect the privacy of
the citizenry at large it's not just New
Hampshire citizens you can imagine uh
maybe people coming from other states to
buy alcohol and tobacco in New Hampshire
for various reasons and so to protect
their personal information this is a
good faith um effort at achieving that
goal
okay so I got one very simple
question who told you that they these
machine these Scanning Machines retain
any information that's on the card
because what I was told is that all it
does is looks at the barcode and helps
the merchant to say yes or no that
they're old enough but there is no
retaining of any personal information
not even retaining that that trans that
event even
occurred so I've been told that the
scanning of the of the identification is
is keeping that whatever scanner the the
store this person is using and others
they they believe that that information
is being scanned so I guess I would look
at the flip side we're getting we're
getting two different pieces of
information fair enough but if if I just
can flesh out my answer please yeah
thank you Mr
chairman if you're correct and I'm
incorrect this bill does no harm and
it's still a good common sense prot
ction to put into place
proactively well I disagree with that
because this bill says scan that the
whole purpose of these scans is so that
the the person who's checking for the ID
doesn't have to do the math to find out
whether that person really is 18 or 21
you know over the years and might be
close close to their birth they show up
on their birthday you know that that
that they want to make sure they get it
right the purpose of the scan is so that
it's Quicky you just to get in it says
yes or
no and you're gone so that you're the
problem with this bill is the word right
out of the beginning the word scan you
need to remove scan you're you're saying
well we're saying you should be allowed
to do a scan for the sole
purpose of saying whether the person is
of age but not worrying and then and
that and then go on to say that it's a
Prohibition to uh record retain or store
not we could leave that language in but
you got to take out the part that allows
them to do the scan in the first place
would you believe Mr Mr chairman once
again I've gotten excellent advice from
you I've I don't think I've ever gotten
bad advice from you I would certainly be
more than willing to uh either have an
amendment drafted uh or or work with a
member of the committee for a friendly
Amendment um that might take Troublesome
language out but still accomplish the
the end goal and I I appreciate the
advice so yes I I I I would not have a
problem with that it's the storage of
the information I have a problem with
perfect thank you now does anybody have
a
question we you can put in a pin card if
you want to speak I did yeah yeah but
you can't ask a question you can put in
a pin card
I okay all right so now we do have a
question we'll start at this end
representative
burough thanks for qu answering my
asking thanks for answering my question
representative um is there is there ever
a legitimate reason for a business to
retain that information that you're
aware
of so thank you for the question and
you're supposed to say thank you for
taking the question because I can refuse
to answer but I thank you for taking the
question I appreciate it very very much
certainly and thank you for being yeah
yeah certainly I I I can I can imagine
that there are commercial transactions
um or perhaps even private
transactions where the storage of that
type of information may be required I am
not an expert in in banking uh but I can
I can imagine that perhaps there are
Financial Vehicles where the institution
um that is you know carrying out those
transactions uh may be required to to
keep that information on on file we we
should note that my understanding of of
this section of law is that a consumer
can consent to having that information
uh copied not scanned copied and and
stored so that the consumer has the
right to say yes or no and choose to
move forward or or not the the the
institution um doesn't and shouldn't
have the right to demand it unless it's
legally required ired somewhere else in
in either RSA or federal code thank you
for the
question represent Walsh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question um I'm just wondering what was
the background to specify pawn broker
scrap metal dealer or secondhand dealer
in this language yes thank you thank you
for the thank you for the question this
is um existing law and so the changes
are the parts that are crossed out which
would be language removed and the
language in bold is the language that
would be added um I'm I'm not sure what
font this is it looks like Times New
Roman so anything that's in a standard
Times New Roman font so not italicized
not bold not crossed out is is already
existing RSA and I I would defer to the
chairman to confirm that that that's
correct
absolutely correct thank you Mr chairman
representative
civan thank you for taking my question
so I actually can get on board with your
intentions here I could definitely see a
world world where people unwillingly are
giving out their information and then
it's being sold and marketed and
whatever without you knowing um but I do
I do see something I haven't seen
addressed yet I'm wondering if you maybe
know or if anybody's talked to you about
it in your in your research before you
made this bill
are these machines designed to maybe
catch fake IDs because I could imagine a
world where you put my my ID in and we
know that I'm of age and so it's fine
but if you put in one and I was 20 it's
going to come up as fake but it might
not be something that I could tell as as
the as the shop owner and it's a good
way to kind of prevent them from being
liable for selling to somebody that
looks like they have a real ID when it's
really fake and that to me seems like if
you don't change it to prevent scanning
or something like that then that seems
like a potential risk that could now be
borne by the the convenience store or
whatever yeah thank you for the question
um so so I I I agree uh with the request
of the the the chair that the word um
scan be be removed because it's it's not
the scanning that's the problem it's the
it's the storage of the information so I
have I have no problem with that I I'm
not familiar with the machines I've
never I've never seen one I've never
operated one uh they certainly don't
scan I don't buy tobacco products um but
I I do buy alcohol from time to time um
and my my identification has never been
never been scanned um for proof of of
age or any other purpose um because
there is such a wide
um breadth and depth of potential
identifications um I I I'm not sure that
the machine is universal I I would
certainly hope that if I showed up at my
my local convenient store to buy um say
a bottle of wine and I was challenged at
the checkout counter for my age and the
only identification I happen to be in
possession of was say uh either my
passport or a p they now have passport
cards right for for land Crossings only
I I would certainly hope that the
retailer would accept that and I I don't
know that these these scanners scan all
50 states I can imagine a tourist coming
down from Canada uh or or some other uh
destination Europe Africa Asia Australia
I hate to leave anybody anybody out um
and their IDs would not match that so
it's simply a a a visual look but to to
remove scan um to Simply um stop the the
the saving of that information I have no
problem with so I think we have
alignment yeah um my understanding is
it's it's a real ID issue it's a real
and that um if you ever want to experien
this I've been told that you can go into
one of those Massachusetts marijuana
stores and they all are required to have
them so Mr chairman is my
understanding that the quote so now
because there's we have to be careful
about language when we talk about real
ID right somebody like me thinks a
driver's license from from the state is
sufficient however the federal
government has imposed uh a pending
regulation of what they call real ID
which essentially Mak a state issued
driver's license a soft passport
although it can't be used for those
purposes right it becomes a federal ID
at that point uh to the best of my
knowledge Massachusetts or any other
state um that I'm aware of that that has
retail sales of cannabis requires a real
ID uh a standard New Hampshire driver's
license is sufficient uh New Hampshire
RSA does not mandate that New Hampshire
citizens obtain a real ID when they
renew their driver's license
and uh the the the the threat of course
is well you can't board a plane unless
you have a real ID well I'm blessed
enough to have a passport passport card
as well as global entry and any of those
uh identifications because they're
Federal are in fact default uh real IDs
so when when we when we're talking about
real ID in the quote as a federal
requirement um I'm not a I'm not aware
of States requiring real ID for cannabis
transactions and uh I don't believe that
that can be mandated in New Hampshire
without Act of the
legislature that's true too thank you
very much for your testimony thank you
appreciate the time uh question is this
of the chair or of me no I I guess it's
for the representative is he willing to
take another question oh certainly uh it
just occurred to me that when I go to a
grocery store all my groceries are
scanned and we going to see a bill in
the future and maybe this is not because
it's it's starting to sound
like we're snowballing into something
are we going to start seeing something
that a law that says that we can't scan
our
groceries thank you for the question so
again I I've already yielded to the
question uh as as brought up by the
chair uh the removal of the word scan
causes me no pause at all I have no
problem removing the word scan for the
for the purposes of identification when
you go to the grocery store they are are
choosing to scan items to determine the
price you your privacy is protected in
that if you pay
cash and you don't have are not
participating in their Rewards program
right because their Rewards program
obviously has your personal
identification if you pay cash then
there's no way to trace back a grocery
sale uh to the person person that made
the the the
purchase great so so to answer the
question no I don't believe that this is
a first step at snowballing to try to
eliminate scanning from
society thank you very much thank you Mr
chairman uh the chair we all call David
Walker representative
Walker and uh Miss Johnson you will be
next but under protocol we always do
reps
first good morning thank you Mr chairman
good morning my name is representative
Dave Walker from Rochester
and I do kind of have uh problem with
the word
scan uh I have my problem with this the
way they do things is a different angle
I recently my uh driver's license
expired and as of December I needed to
get one of these which is a temporary
one while I'm waiting for the mail to
come well if I go to a
store and I want to buy an alcoholic
beverage or a cigar or cigarettes or
whatever they want to scan it's
mandatory to scan it well this doesn't
have a barcode cuz it's a temporary so
if you hand them a passport that doesn't
scan either so you're turned away and
you cannot buy alcohol or tobacco unless
you scan it so unless they go back to
due diligence where I last I knew I
don't look under 21 and they did the old
man with a white beard down to here did
but that we were
both denied and left so I think there
needs to be something changed in that
law that's you don't have to scan if you
don't have a barcode on your temporary
driver's license or your or your barcode
or your passport so that's where I
really have a problem is that you have
to scan or they don't serve you they
don't yeah but but that's that
establishment's
policy that they only do scan other
words we don't we don't statutorily
require that that that if they have a
policy that says his me I I always used
to laugh when I went you know in the
Boston Garden you know that you know
they would card me and I said well I
know my hair is platinum but it's not
the Platinum you might be thinking but
so I I assume that uh if you're that
vendor that whoever you went to to buy
liquor or cigarettes and a would known
you from the past cuz you you're regular
or maybe not actually and and and said
is no I cannot sell it to you because
it's their store policy that they have
to
scan the legislature can't fix that
problem well because the word scan is in
the law that's their interpretation of
it and it's multiple places well right
now the we don't have any no the scan's
not in them in the law at
all that's what they're doing and right
that's their policy they the law and
then even though I am a regular customer
at this establishment they know I'm 61
years old I'm pretty sure they didn't
card you but if they did they did card
me okay and they and they wouldn't they
refused to sell to you correct because
there's no barcode on a temporary
driver's license and didn't you look at
the person in the eye and say yeah and
they look back at means said it's our
store policy they're going to get fired
if they didn't I would write a letter to
the editor of your local Rochester paper
and let everybody know that that
establishment is
fickle I was actually thinking of
picketing the thing but that's
fine but it's more than one store it's
not just this one there was others in
Rochester that did the same
thing fair enough we have any other
questions for the committee members
seeing none we thank you very much thank
you chair will now call in Deborah
Johnson from Grandam who is in support
of the bill and I hope you're not going
to really take 15 minutes we'll see I I
brought information I gave it to you um
thank you to the chair and to the people
for listening to me I would ask you uh
first of all since you asking you're
you're you're unclear as to what is
saved in here to turn to this third Leaf
of the the uh packet I gave you yeah
turn to the third
Leaf before I actually say what I have
to
say and about what what what these
systems
do just uh why don't you since we don't
have enough for everybody would you
please read to me what you think is
important that they know this is one of
the the systems that's online that you
can find um it's called bizcard reader
scan ID scan ID is a powerful card
scanning software which helps you scan
manage and maintain driver licenses and
other identification cards it's scans
and stores driver driver licenses
medical and insurance cards and other
photo IDs and creates a searchable
database of the scan cards it reads the
pdf417 barcodes on us and Canadian
driver's licenses and automatically
places the information from the barcode
into the respective name birth date
address and other fields it also has a
built-in OCR engine which allows you to
drag and drop data directly on from the
scanned IM image to any text field I
can't read the the uh you could pass it
around there's pictures of what it what
it brings in I want you to note that it
also brings in the the driver's Li the
whole picture of the driver's license
with signatures there every there the
information on on the driver's license
everything your height your weight your
your date of birth um your driver's
license number your address it's all on
there including your signature tell me
that's
not uh I I I I've studied this for for
quite a while but I now I will read you
my
statement house Commerce and consumer
affairs and this is also in your packet
thank you for addressing this issue that
threatens The public's ability to prot
protect against identity theft and other
dangers associated with private
identifying information since delving
into this issues I issue I have come
across other threats to individual
rights to keep themselves safe from
identity theft in this packet there's a
screenshot of the information collected
from driver's licenses and saved to
databases this is only one example of
the applications being marketed for this
purpose which begs the question of how
the federal law also included in this
packet is being
ignored that was by the way that federal
law uh was done in 1993 Barbara Boxer um
was the uh sponsor of that bill and that
bill was created because a celebrity was
tracked down by her driver's license
information coming into the wrong hands
and she was killed and that's why that
bill was made but by by not doing this
we are ignoring the the federal
law
um while I first noticed and sounded of
the alarm regarding the scanning I
witnessed inconvenience stores when
standing behind customers during alcohol
and tobacco
purchases uh My article in Granite grock
brought comments from others that that
point out other venues where driver's
licenses are being scanned I was
notified that Macy's department store
was scanning in order to prove identity
during credit card transaction
additionally some election polls are
using scanning rather than just viewing
IDs these are other examples that might
give consideration to broaden this the
title of this bill so is made clear that
all driver's license scanning is
prohibited except for those specified in
the law for decades I've been alarmed at
how casually our social security numbers
are used in various businesses for proof
of identity those of us over a certain
age might remember that these numbers
were originally strictly limited to
employment use only that was the promise
when created
today we see identity theft is running
rampid and this is one of the key pieces
last summer I chose to give up my
position as a lake host after four years
of service because I became aware that
without first notifying staff New
Hampshire Lakes put employee information
in cloud-based Human Resources software
including full name address email birth
date and social security number it took
over took over a week for them to take
my information out of that system once I
object objected resigned and demanded
that they de delete my record from the
cloud during the back and forth I was
told that the that the system is very
secure that same month the military
employment data of the UK had been
hacked and I sent New Hampshire Lakes a
newspaper report covering that event I
have since learned that this style of
human resource management is becoming
widespread practice I urge you all to be
vigilant in protecting the public
against the danger of identity theft in
every possible area um I I have included
the federal law in this pack it's on the
on the starts on the back of the uh the
letter um I included uh links to other
there's a ton of these systems that are
being marketed online that collect our
data store them in a database and uh it
needs to stop and I I object to taking
the word scan out of out of this law um
it actually this law needs to be
broadened and and made so that our our
identity is protected and I hope that
our representatives are willing to do
that because this this world is getting
to be a scary place anybody have any
questions for
me representative spear has a
question the scanner that you're
referencing here is that the kind of
scanner we're talking about maybe the
alcohol commission can tell us if it's
the same one I I I I will tell you that
I did um write to and went through uh
weeks of going back and forth with the
Attorney General's office and I asked
them if they because they they told us
that um well they told if you if you
look at the New Hampshire law what it
what it originally said which is crossed
out on here is um unless authorized by
the department of safety and basically
if you go to the Department of Safety
and that's in this packet too um it has
their their rule
um it's it's on the on the back of the
second Leaf of this
um and and the and the department of
safety rule basically basically it says
yeah go ahead scan I mean it says
notwithstanding any rule of the contrary
the department authorizes the scanning
of personal information from any license
in electronic form or format so long as
all of the following conditions are met
the equipment used to scan such personal
information does not visibly identify
any personal information other than
driver's license number and name the
equipment used to scan the personal
information does not retain store or
transfer any personal information other
than driver's license number and name
for any period of time and the equipment
used to scan the personal information
does not store any personal information
other than the driver's license number
and name in a central repository
Disaster Recovery Central
repository such as cold site or hot site
whether on site or in a remote location
I asked the Attorney General um when I
complained about this to them
originally um and and they basically you
know said it's it's all okay I mean I've
got all of this here I asked well did
you go out and and check these scanners
to make sure that they're not doing any
of this I got no answer I got blown
off where where I'm having a follow on
further question you may inquire iOS to
follow on
question thank
you uh where where I'm having a problem
with this is that
80% of all of our transactions happen
with credit cards so you have
no safety as far as your identity is
concerned so just I don't know what
color is now you can do cash you can
certainly do cash so my question is
there are scanners that don't store
that's a
fact we see them in the grocery store
all the
time I think you have to be a little bit
more circumspect as to what type of
scanning you're talking about I like
know that where do I find that out where
do I find out what these are collecting
who's going to find out for us we need
that
when further question you may inquire
this is not really a question maybe this
is you for you to answer would you
believe oh you want me to answer
okay when someone has a complaint about
anything they go to Consumer uh consumer
protection if you feel there's a problem
then you go to consumer prot I did that
I have all the back and forth right here
and they did nothing I I was I I guess
that's exactly
right okay so uh the good news is this
bill is going to go to a subcommittee
where we're going to drill down and
really get to the heart of the issue
here's what I can tell you at this
moment two three
26312 this RSA that's in is under the
Department of Safety relative to
Driver's
Licenses so in terms of normally with
this committee we we probably had never
have never delved into this RSA in this
committee we would do consumer
protection and we would have our own
statute that say with violation of the
consumer protection act for anybody to
store information that was gained
through scanning of a driver's license
we that's the way we would probably
write it simple as that how however
whether that's the right answer or not
whether what we're dealing with in terms
of figuring out what's going on with
this license statute we will resolve
that in the uh subcommittee the last
thing I want to say to you is is that it
is very interesting that you said there
is actually a federal
law and that who enforces the federal
law not the state well the state can be
find for the federal law I'm just saying
that
obviously obviously the federal attorney
general's office has that right to find
States for selling marijuana but they
don't do that either okay so they have
chosen not to enforce that statute
that's not our problem our issue is how
do we deal with our
licenses whe whether real ID or not how
we deal with our licenses in our state
and what information someone attempts to
acquire from a credit card or excuse me
from a driver's license the policy has
always been and uh that I've seen and I
know I'm I'm tracking my mind but I know
I've seen before how um it is uh other
in terms of illegal that that you're not
uh and I remember was uh it was car
dealers when they loan cars out to
people that they take a copy of your
driver's license
when they loan your car to you that they
are allowed to do that but they must
destroy that license when you return the
car like that copy I think that's where
what I'm reaching back to so um we will
try to delve into this and get the right
answer here but as you well will begin
to see um there are a fair amount of
Industries and businesses in the state
who would are very concerned with the
language of this bill as it's currently
I'm concerned with the I'm concerned
with the fact that these are being
scanned I have an addition I'd like to
make to the bill that any business
that's using a scanner must have go
through some some
process uh through the attorney general
or whoever would do it to make sure that
that scanner is not storing that
information I think that would be
weights and measures like we do with our
gas stations so I thought I would like
to if if if you're going to allow any
kind of scanner to be used then they
should
be they they there there should be a
process to make sure that those scanners
are only checking for uh the birth date
or whatever
but fair enough you have to you have to
protect our safety we we're under attack
all the time with our our our private
information I agree does anybody else
have any more questions for me I have a
lot of information here but so we see
you when we do the subcommittee next
week you're doing a subcommittee next
week and you want me to come to that yes
we'd love to have you there and what is
the time I haven't scheduled it yet but
it'll be it'll be it'll be either
Wednesday it'll probably be Wednesday
stay tuned so I'll try to keep Thursday
free but it'll be Wednesday thank you
very much thank you okay gief
armag in our new protocol the next up
would be a state
enforcer who theoretically would be the
one who would
enforce but you're obviously it's
Department of Safety which you used to
do that so you probably know about this
statute 28 years of that
right uh we're going to tag team this so
uh Danielle will come up here shortly uh
again for the record uh my name is uh
Chief Mark armaganian director of liquor
enforcement licensing with me here today
is uh as you have already met uh deputy
chief Danielle ston deputy director of
the same entity um we're going to tag
team this because there there are a lot
of moving Parts first and foremost from
from head of division um we appreciate
first of all I appreciate totally the
words of Representative testifying here
today uh privacy is I think first and
foremost in most of our heads um in the
retaining of information um really
concerns people like uh uh like was just
testified to um we are not seeing that
in our in our purview um and what we are
seeing more not only from a law
enforcement point of view so I we wear a
couple of hats here and not only can I
speak from my vision eight years ago
from 28 years with Department of Safety
State Police but also from a law
enforcement point of view and a
regulatory point of view because as all
of you know and we've testified a ton of
times we're trying to keep the
vulnerable age group safe at the same
time we're trying to protect our lenses
from fictitious the use of fictitious
IDs um and um to be quite honest about
and Danielle we'll talk more about it
those in the vulnerable age group that
might have
nefarious ideas of purchasing alcohol of
not of legal age we need some sort of
verification
process um uh so with that in mind um I
I appreciate and I love the process that
goes on here of talking out bills um
scan the lack of scanning really hurts
this uh initiative um of verifying age
not retaining information
is Paramount we understand that so in
listening to the previous testimony that
was given uh from from the
representative to to the committee here
um it puts a smile on our face as we see
this morph into something that is usable
to not only law enforcement uh scanning
licenses because in the world of
efficiencies and Effectiveness if you go
into any Cruiser in this state barring
just a small group because of you know
monetary reasons um you will find that
information going into accident reports
running licenses verification of
identities that's all done by scanning
that is technology as we look at it
today like representative spear said I
scanning groceries all the way through
scanning Drive scanning is uh a way of
life now that that we deal with for
efficiencies so um we we understand what
is being said what is being brought
forward um and we like the position of
the committee and and uh especially you
Mr chairman uh that we could take this
product and make it better uh in
subcommittee so Danielle will give some
technical information uh as it relates
to it and then we'll be open for
questions good morning again um
I do think it's important um
specifically with the law proposes it's
prohibiting the scanning for the
verification of age for the purchase of
Alcohol Tobacco product um this is a
tool we see um used throughout the
industry for lenses to further assist
them with verifying age um as I stated
before in my previous testimony when you
get the liquor license and you or
tobacco license you as the licy incumber
the liability to ensure that the people
purchasing the product are of age so I
do think we need to give them every
option and every tool available for them
to use to do that because even as a lie
you also are then expecting your clerk
to verify that age so that you yourself
as the L holder don't get in trouble so
we do see this used uh significantly
throughout the industry as a tool to
verify age what we have seen um in most
of our license establishments is what
the chairman talked about previously is
Red Light Green Light the ID is scanned
it's basically scanned into a calculator
that says yes this person is 21 or not
21 um we have seen some development of
these uh point of sale systems which
help to identify fake IDs um I can tell
you that fictitious IDs and the quality
of these fake IDs has significantly
improved in the last 5 to 10 years um we
do training constantly on these they are
very hard to um identify that they are
fake we see these tools used um
primarily in college towns as well where
you know the fake IDs are coming in in
in uh in cases in the mail um so I do
think it is important to keep this as a
tool for the lenes one thing I do want
to point out is that um again like I
said before we're not in the business of
telling the leny how to run their
business they have to ensure that
everybody that is purchasing alcohol and
tobacco is of age how they do that is up
to them we have LIC CES that require IDs
by every Patron that comes in and
purchases Alcohol Tobacco doesn't matter
if you're 21 doesn't matter if you're 91
you have to that is their store policy
you have to present an ID we have uh
licensed establishments who with a
temporary ID require another form of
backup with that temporary ID they are
able to put any restriction on that
policy that they feel helps them run
their business in compliance and and in
safety so um I do think there's a you'll
see a broad spectrum of policies when it
comes to is a passport C passport
accepted is a passport card accepted by
Statute you can accept that as an age
verification tool but the lcy does not
have to accept them if they choose not
to if they choose to say we're not
accepting passports here for the
purchase of alcohol and tobacco they
have the ability to do that so in terms
of what you're going to see um in the
policy of iding we've we've seen all of
it uh yes sometimes it's scanned there's
even Point of Sales Systems out there
that actually don't allow the sale to go
through unless there's there's a
scanning that's the point of sale system
they've decided to purchase that's the
policy that they've put in place so I
think you're going to see a variety of
policies and procedures with this but I
do think it is an important tool for the
industry to have um but we again we
agree the information should not be
stored it should simply be for Edge
verification um for that purchase to to
happen and if I can just uh further
furthermore I have had uh direct
conversations uh and I apologize I was
looking at my phone with director John
morasco of the Division of Motor Vehicle
um he him and I have been talking uh
consistently within the last two weeks
on this very issue of scanning um he has
proposed anva uh the association of uh
uh motor vehicle um uh motor vehicle
administrators thank you thank you Tom
um and and it is a red light green light
um uh initiative um I don't know how it
works I'm going to be seeing a test of
it uh to see exactly what that uh
entails at the same time it might be
something for him to give a uh maybe a
tutorial on that in front of the
committee here so you can all see it
again um
there is no retention of any information
it is age
verification uh as Daniel has said we
have seen errors even on the vertical
licenses that actually spell out in a
banner when the person turns 21 the math
the human error involved in doing the
math or just reading comprehension
because they're sometimes people get
nervous asking those
questions um a little bit of a lack of a
better term a little bit of a flat spin
happens and they discount what the
license is actually saying to them and
and that sale is made to an underage
person when it says they're 19 years old
it let alone the license turned sideways
and it's sideways it's it's that of an
underage person um and like I said the
math has been done for you on the
license on the face of the license it
tells you when the person is going to
turn 21 so so this is a tool as Danielle
said to help the
licensees and I'm sure you'll hear from
industry too that it would handicap them
quite quite uh
substantially but I'm sorry to add to
that but just give you a little bit more
information M has a question uh thank
you very much Mr chairman and thanks for
taking my question I'm just curious on I
just recently got my license renewed and
I got a a real license which I had to
bring in additional documents but my
question is on the on a the Hampshire
license does the
barcode actually confirm my age and so
what what's actually in the
barcode that thank you for your question
representative I think that's a better
question I I can wing it um but I think
it's a better question for the director
motor vehicle um in winging it what the
these systems that we're familiar with
are actually as Danielle said they're
they're they're a calculator so they're
extracting or looking at the date of
birth in the code are they is there a
chip in the card or is it just looking
at the bar code I think it's a QR code
on the back the new ones are QR codes
the old ones used to be magnetic codes
okay so they're just looking the QR code
and then doing the math yep question
follow I I would would think that to if
if that information was in the barcode
not only the age but the name or
whatever it would be very difficult for
somebody to make a phony license and so
um if if they don't do that I I would
think a scanner
should should know that information so
to speak just yeah thank you thank you
again representative um as Danielle has
stated The Fakes over overseas are
really good they're really good yeah
anybody can make a QR code and and the
information on the front of those LIC
are
embedded I'm sorry Mr yeah I was just
saying if there was a chip in it it
would be a different story y but because
it's a a QR code I mean that's as common
as I turn on my evening news and there's
a QR code on the screen for where I
should send money to if I could if I
could clarify so um we have just to be
clear we have seen fake IDs that do scan
so they they actually pass the scanning
tool the ly is not held responsible for
that if it's a high qual the statute
allows for that if it's a high quality
fake ID they do their due diligence to
check those IDs if they sell to a
fraudulent ID they're not held liable um
it runs the game and again there's very
very high quality fake IDs so this is
why even if we're asked should I get a
you know sometimes the last should we
get one again it's a business decision
based on the licy it's a tool it's not
the end all it's not the fail safe you
know um it's not something if it's a
very you know if if you if I present
your ID and it scans and you make the
stale you didn't do your dual diligence
and still checking that ID just because
it scanned and said you made the sale
I'm very clearly not you so um it's not
a a fail safe for the ly it's not an end
all saying if you have this you're not
liable for anything it's just a tool for
they have but yes there are fake IDs
there there the majority of fake IDs do
not skin but there are fake IDs out
there that we have encountered that do
scan in certain systems so it's it's ID
based it's system based it's it's
technology not like my Global where I
they I don't even hint them anything
they just take my picture and they can
tell whether who I am okay
representative
salie thank you for taking my question
uh my question is I do understand
scanning is important it's efficiency
purpose accuracy and all we save money
also but any automation comes with some
kind of a respon responsibility of the
people who are implementing that system
so I would like to know two things
number one do you guys have audit in
place which you guys do quarterly or six
month to make sure that this policies
has been implemented and you do do you
have the record of that and how many
audits has been done by the owner of the
system in last three
years so we're not um responsible for
the systems uh we're not responsible for
auditing the system this statute is a is
under safety it's not under the liquer
yeah it's safety me if somebody is
basically saying that they are going to
scan my private information they need to
have a system in place to protect my
information and only way the customer
will have some kind of a uh some kind of
a basically they are comfortable if
there is a audit in place and which has
to be followed and it has to to be
followed with certain kind of a
guidelines would you believe would you
believe yeah we need to be what you were
going to say would you believe would you
believe yes perfect thank you you're
teaching me that's fine thank you very
much I I trying to emphasize for you
freshman we're not judging we we're just
you know in terms of our opinion we
don't we don't want to know your opinion
in the hearing yeah that is correct okay
we don't know all we're trying to do is
get information from the public and from
the Departments and people who are
affected by the legislation but then
once we get into the subcommittee an
exact session then you're free to yeah
go crazy on your opinion no I would
rather basically ask the question and
they let them be prepared for the next
session and yes if I if I can add into
this Mr chairman thank you uh again for
your question Mr representative um I
think also because this bill is pointed
at tobacco and alcohol we think liquor
enforcement but really the oversight is
safety and there are other departments
throughout state that actually have
oversight of POS systems and that so so
it's a great question um that has to be
pointed at the right people um in the
room so um but at at the end of the day
uh we try to do our due diligence we
understand what everybody's concerns are
and we're not snubbing them at all thank
you thank
you thanks for taking a question I just
want to understand the process so when
the scanning scanning is done does it uh
connect with the Department of Motor
Vehicles or somewhere to validate that
the scan is
correct Sy
so the amb system does do that from what
I've been told but I'm sorry it was a
very brief conversation that I had with
the director of Motor Vehicle so that's
going to be a bigger conversation and
maybe he can come to the subcommittee to
testify in front of you um the systems
that we're talking about uh like our own
are localized systems that pretty much
do the math for you it's a calculator
within the POS system that just figures
out your age and that's it it doesn't
retain information at all now is that
everybody I don't know um there's been
some compelling information that's been
given to us uh today that says that
there are systems out there that retain
information um which is against state
law and those those issues have to be
brought up to the proper authorities um
but there are others that don't retain
information and just figure out Age and
and that's what we're here to just make
sure we can protect and again I really
appreciate what the representative and
Mr chairman you have said with each
other um uh because it's in our eyes
it's going in the right
direction thank you thank you great
thank you very much uh I have three
cards in opposition and I see another
card hiding there whether she's going to
show up or not um I would say that um
it's a chair I have have been around for
a while so I I can I scan the room and
always keep in an eye on the room and I
do know that there is the bank
commissioner and represent the bank
Department because I believe I'm record
I'm require they're required to copy
that driver's license and keep it as
part of the file when I could do my
mortgage so that again would say to me
is that that the statute probably put it
in the consumer protection act bank is
exempt from it so it might cover all
businesses except those four Industries
but we have to decide how we want to
handle that but um there it in this case
I think that this bill is uh um it it's
probably in the wrong statute to for
enforcement okay having said that Tom
parasol representing the Hampshire
retail association in opposition to the
bill and please do not repeat anything
that's already been said
great thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record my name is
Tom prol uh from deur prol and Thomas
and I'm here today representing the New
Hampshire retail association um I
understand you've heard a lot of
information and that this bill will be
going to a subcommittee so I will keep
my testimony uh brief I do want to say
that uh the New Hampshire retail
association represents about 350 members
uh Statewide of all different sizes and
we also recognize that this bill is an
attempt to protect the privacy of of
individuals and I want to assure you
that that is also a Cornerstone part of
what the retail establishments do um one
thing I do want to point you to uh and
this will all come out during
subcommittee which I more than happy to
participate in is there are currently
rules around the law that is exists and
that is safe C 566.062
[Music]
about obtaining the information um to
verify the identity of the consumer and
also about not using the information
whole or in part obtained from license
um to link with any other database um in
addition to that there are also safety
protections that were established in a
bill that was adopted I believe two
years ago Senate Bill 255 relative to
privacy which requires uh businesses to
have a mechanism for folks to purge
their information from any system so
that information uh is is already out
there as well um I just want to go on
record saying that retail establishments
do take age verification very seriously
and this is as uh deputy chief Ellison
mentioned a tool they have in the toolbx
to ensure that they are complying with
the age restriction laws in the state
with that I will keep my testimony at
that answer possibly any questions I can
and I look forward to the subcommittee
next week perfect thank you very much
chair we'll call on Rich Parsons of the
New Hampshire Grocers
Association good morning Rich Parsons um
R young pelli representing the New
Hampshire groceries Association um we
are also opposed to this bill today for
similar reasons that have already been
said I thought I was going to give you
some new information about the Privacy
Bill SB 255 that Tom mentioned but he
beat me to it that law just went into
effect January 1st and allows the
consumer to to figure out what
information any business is collecting
on them in the state and be able to have
that information deleted um the the
attorney general just put out a document
on it actually yesterday so um my
testimony kind of speaks for itself on
the importance of being able to scan for
age restricted products to ensure we
don't have severe penalties um you know
the red light green light system was
already disc discuss but that is what
the system that is in place for the
folks that do scan U that we've heard
they do that kind of they scan it gives
them a red light or a green light um and
we otherwise abide by all federal and
state the new state privacy laws as well
so with that I'll take any
questions any
questions seeing none thank you very
much Chris gagan from the New England
convenience store Association
now you can see all the different lenses
that we have for off premises liquor
sales good morning chairman uh good
morning Representatives uh for the
record my name is Chris gagen I'm the
safety director for halfers uh gas
stations uh halfers is a family run
business that's been around for about a
100 years uh we have 70 retail locations
uh across three states 11 of which are
in the state of New Hampshire um at our
retail stores we prioritize the safety
and well-being of our employees and
Community above everything else we hold
Three core values strong to our heart
one fueled by family it's not just our
individual families but the families
that come and visit our uh stores and
purchase from our stores you are our
family in general always doing the right
thing taking ownership of the things
that we do dayto
day and doing it in a way that makes
sense both for the company as well as
for our customers and then safety in
everything that we do this is our
strongest value we hold and we believe
that if we have a safe working
environment for our employees and a safe
atmosphere for our customers we're
making a change for our communities for
halfers scanning IDs when selling
alcohol and tobacco isn't just about
following the law it's about protecting
our families doing the right thing for
our customers and ensuring a safer
future for our youth we use the ID
scanning technology which can
confidentially verify every customer's
age reducing the the risk of underage
sales and preventing harmful products
from getting into the wrong hands
without this technology the store Andor
the associate would be at an increased
risk of violations caused by human error
it's a small but crucial step that helps
us build trust with our customers while
upholding our responsibility to the
community and our core
values our system does not store any
personal information and by physically
scanning the ID it helps our Associates
accurately verify a customer's Aid age
reducing the risk of illegal sales to
miners for us it's not just about the
transaction it's it's a commitment to
family Integrity safety and the vales
that values that make our neighborhood
strong thank you very much any questions
from the committee members I think
they're all question and doubt I feel so
thank you I appreciate it and we have
one card left Kate fry from new futures
also in opposition to the
bill good afternoon members of the
committee my name is Kate fry I'm the
vice president of advocacy at new
Futures we are an organization that
works on health and wellness policies um
I uh specialize in the area of substance
misuse so I would just say I'm not I'm
just going to add additional um
information most of what
um my thoughts are have been said um but
we know that uh checking IDs is an
important measure both for preventing
alcohol and um tobacco misuse and
underage use the only thing that I was
hoping that the Liquor Commission would
bring up is that there could be some
federal laws uh Federal funding at stake
if our non-compliance rates dip for um
tobacco
regulations um states are required under
the Sinar law to meet a certain amount
of um do a certain amount of inspections
and compliance checks if that non
compliance check Falls below 20% Then
Federal funding could be at risk um so
I'm just saying this is an effective
tool first as uh was said earlier by The
Liquor Commission if this is a tool that
businesses rely on to make sure they're
in compliance and also um protecting
their liability we feel that it's
important to have an option and I will
just go on record saying that we just
believe the rec it should be scanned we
would not want any business to keep
private information that they should not
have thank you very much any questions
from the committee members seeing none
is there anybody else who would like to
speak on House Bill
77 I get the right bill number they did
seeing none we'll close the public
hearing and I did it before noon look at
that
what we have
two so if you look at this this is how
it is so when the time gets when the
time gets announced like even if we
finish early like like we finished this
one early we had to wait until we got to
that time you can't
start because other people will yeah
you
wel
e
e e
okay we open up the public Hearing in
House Bill 79 and hear from the prime
sponsor representative leechman good
afternoon represent lean
so good afternoon Mr chairman if you
look like the representative Washington
uh without your suit coat on up
there we have a failed heating system
here and it's aide to be on full full
blast so it's really warm down here
anyway for the record Mr chairman my
name is Peter lean I represent the towns
of petero and Sharon and I'm here to
address uh House Bill
79 as the chairman knows I've taken a
particular interest in The Liquor
Commission over the years and have filed
certain pieces of
legislation um this legislation as you
can see is just to establish a
commission to look at the Liquor
Commission to see whether it should be
privatized or not it's not saying it
should or it shouldn't but I think it's
time that we give a real good look um I
have probably the disadvantage of of
serving on the finance committee where
my division looks at The Liquor
Commission and for a a long period of
time now there's been significant growth
in expenses but not a corresponding
increase in
Revenue I just looked at the revenue
figures for um the last six months it's
kind of disappointing the revenues are
down uh nearly uh well
18.7% over plan that's a significant
amount of money it makes it difficult
for us uh to find the money to keep the
state going and again uh we've seen a
lot of increase in expense but not a
corresponding increase in revenues so
with that Mr chairman I would certainly
entertain any questions I know there are
people behind me that also wish to
speak okay representative mcleer has a
question thank you chairman um thank you
for taking my question where is this
expense coming from any any particular
area is IT personnel is it uh location
rents you know uh Personnel is a Big
Driver um last the last budget cycle I
actually wrote that down to make sure I
had the correct numbers The Liquor
Commission had up 343 and they were
asking for an increase so bring the
number of employees up to
371 uh there are expenses they're
building rather attractive um liquor
stores around the state and there is an
expense there they're not paid for right
out of the gate they're paid for over a
period of time so I think it's important
to at least get a group of people
together not only legislators but people
that are affected by the industry to see
whether it makes sense to private ties
or not uh James Farah who I think you
may know he's now U at the Legislative
Office he's our key person over there
the number one person I talked to James
who used to work for the liquor commit
Mission and he said that we'd probably
realize over a billion dollars if that
was sold it's all again it would only be
one time money but perhaps if we had an
appropriate uh fee or tax structure we'd
make just as much money without owning
The Liquor Commission as we do now
thanks for your
question representative Gibbs thank you
Mr chair um just a question about
building of new liquor stores obviously
that's a big expense but isn't
construction usually paid for Via
bonding rather than out of the general
budget it's paid for by money from The
Liquor Commission so any if they if they
have a bond it's actually money that
does come from The Liquor Commission
fund it's not General funds if you will
for another use aren't being paid to you
know build liquor
stores sure representative pusk uh thank
you Mr chairman I thank you for taking
my question representative uh if memory
serves two years ago four years ago
there were efforts to uh get rid of the
Liquor Commission uh how is this bill
here significantly different than two
years ago's Bill except for the fact
that this now uh creates a commission
thank you now this looks at a commission
to make a recommendation of the
legislature whether it should be
privatized or not so it's not forcing a
decision yet on the legislature the
commission may come back with a uh
recommendation that it works well now or
it may come back and say it needs more
study or maybe we should privatize it so
it's opening it up for further review
and getting people outside of the
legislature
involved
sure representative
post thank you Mr chair um so so with
this is uh starting a commission is
there an expense to that the only
expense would be to pay legislators to
commute it's within the bill so there
wouldn't be any money given to say
someone that was appointed by their
Restaurant Association or the U Attorney
General's office which is mentioned in
the bill so it's just mileage for
legislators okay thank
you representative
burrow thank you Mr Mr chair and thank
you for taking my
question from what I've learned the the
decline in sales of Revenue are across
the across many states because the
increase in consumption of cannabis and
I wonder if you've looked at that and
have drawn any conclusions from that
I've heard that I don't know um how much
truth there is to that uh generally
liquor sales are down worldwide I
believe uh people aren't drinking as
much as they used to uh um it's dry
January so probably the revenue figures
for next month will be even worse than
they are for the last six months but I'm
sure cannabis is having an impact even
though it's allegedly illegal in New
Hampshire
still and also the biggest competitor
Total Wines has doubled the amount of
stores they have in Massachusetts so
that would cut into who's usually one of
our major customers is Massachusetts
resident
oh you're absolutely
correct representative Ammon thank you
Mr chair thank you for other testimony
um we've heard some complaints that
there's too many
commissions and uh there's a suggestion
that I heard earlier today to cut two
commissions for every one you
create this wouldn't be a good one to do
that too well you this isn't cre yet
this would be the one you create right
so if if you have you would you give it
any thought to trim down some other
commissions do you have two commissions
you want to get rid of yeah you know to
be honest with you I I don't know
whether the commissions have been
proposed yet I haven't seen any that
have hit my radar but I hope this would
be one that you'd consider because it's
an issue that I think really should be
addressed because of declining revenue
and um whether we want to continue on a
path with a part of state government
that in my opinion probably should be
handled in private hands versus the
state running of the Liquor
Commission but that's up for the
commission Mr chairman would the revenue
to the state be radically reduced if it
was in private hands I don't believe so
but we as you already know generate over
$800 million here and we generally get
around a $100 million back so to me
it seems a little lopsided when you're
bringing in over $800 million and
declining revenues and generally we're
in the 100 plus or minus range at the
end of the year I don't have my numbers
in front of you but I think those
numbers are wrong so representative
spear I I know that uh that you look at
the numbers and you and you see all that
but just off the top of your
head what would you hope hope to gain if
we did privatize I mean what do you see
as a possibility
there from my own experience in the U
business I'm in outside of the
legislature I'm actually in the railroad
business this is heavily regulated by
the government and where the government
has stepped back uh within the industry
there's been more profitability actually
more
safety um I think generally business
runs Private Business runs better than
govern government has proven that um
most government agencies are more
expensive to oversee and run than
Private Industry so um my guess is that
the expenses would be eliminated
obviously if the Liquor Commission was
privatized and all we would actually be
looking to gain is taxes from Liquors
and wine
sales representative Sullivan thanks for
taking my question I'm just curious if
you know and maybe it's for the liqu
commission when they come up afterwards
but presumably we want some sort of
Liquor Commission to stick around to you
know make sure that they're following
regulations that we have in place do we
know if those are broken up separately
or those just all costs in which case
those costs wouldn't be eliminated would
we were we to um privatize yeah
enforcement is they already have an
enforcement division as I'm sure you
know that's part of their expense MH uh
you'll see in the bill it asks for the
someone from the Department of Safety to
be involved um there's been a long
debate
between legislators the department of
safety's been involved in some of this
discussion whether this state state
police should oversee enforcement versus
a separate enforcement agency within
liquor uh you still have to have
somebody like an enforcement arm it
probably would fall to the Department of
Revenue Administration that does
cigarettes right now or some maybe a
smaller agency within state government
but you'd still need enforcement you'd
still need the taxing author
to go out and make sure that the taxes
were paid on Lor sales so some cost
there would be some cost for sure thank
you but that's something again I think
the commission would discuss and
determine what kind of costs there will
be this is just again opening the the
door to take a look at what we should be
doing going
forward representative
Herbert uh thanks for recognizing me
thanks for coming in sure my question
is if we were to privatize and there are
a lot of privatizations of public assets
going on right now not all of them
successful but uh would the cost of a
liquor go up you would be a great member
to be on that Commission because that
would be I think a question that the
commission may be able to address
because I'm sure you'd hear from people
outside maybe people that are selling
already in our neighboring state to tell
us whether the cost would go up or down
but that would certainly be a question
that the commission should answer
yeah
repres thank you chair thanks for taking
my call um my question is we have uh
right now decent jobs through this
activity done through the government do
you think that by doing a privatizing
are the this are we basically cutting
down the good jobs and we are trying to
get into privatization to make profit
for very few people and trying to cut
the cost and get the profit that is the
objective of privatization or what is
the objective of
privatization well again I think uh all
these stores would still require
employees they would not be working for
the State anymore and be a
responsibility of the state they'd be
working for a private entity but that
again maybe the commission would come
back and say it just doesn't work and it
should stay the way it
is representative pelli thank you for um
letting me ask the question and thank
you for the interesting bill so is it I
guess I just want to understand the work
product that's coming out of this
commission so is it your intention from
this commission to do a detailed cost
benefit analysis and you know really do
a deep dive into the into the um profit
and loss and make that recommendation
and if it is do you have the right
makeup on this Commission
well that would be my hope but certainly
this committee could add or subtract
they may feel that chairman hunt should
share the commission to look into this
but that would certainly be my hope that
they would do a deep dive I've served on
a number of commissions in the past and
it's been my experience that members of
a commission take their jobs very
seriously and often do a very deep dive
in the
subject representative burrow and
representative Gibbs thank you and thank
you for taking my question question and
it kind of um dovetails what the
representative um representative said
previously I'm concerned about the 1400
people who work for the Liquor
Commission and as you said some of them
may fold into a new a new uh private
system um and I lost what I was going to
say but um would it perhaps be less
disruptive to have bring in somebody who
can put together a new marketing program
a new marketing plan rather than just
closing shop on everything that we have
again this is just a commission to look
at all those questions so if the
commission was formed you could
certainly go before the commission and
raise those concerns before they issue
their final
report sure represent Gibbs thank you Mr
chair um this kind of a followup to
representative Sullivan's question about
enforcement um would it be expected that
the report of this commission would
include recommendations as to which
agency
or or would there be a separate agency
that would handle the enforcement
functions if the liquor store function
was privatized yes as you'll see in the
bill it's uh under section one C it
talks about the department of safety
being involved in this commission as you
know the department of safety takes care
of State Police and safety matters
across the street and that's why I
thought their involvement would be
important because they could certainly
speak to the enforc and cost of
enforcing liquor
laws
sure thank you very much nice to see you
Mr chairman nice to see you and I'm glad
to hear that you know your privatization
was is more efficient and I'm sure you
could run an Trak cheaper than the
federal government well our friends as
you know across the border we've talked
about this the MBTA is hundreds of
millions of dollars in debt
so anyway thank you
John okay chair will call on marjerie
Smith represent Smith who's in support
Bill good afternoon good a afternoon
thank you it is always a pleasure to
appear before chairman Hunt's Commerce
Committee um I'm delighted to be here
and I must begin by saying that I don't
agree with the prime
sponsor excuse me um although I am a
co-sponsor and that to me is exactly why
we need a commission seems to me that
when people say it's not about the money
you know it's about the money there is
no reason otherwise for the state to be
in the liquor business um it's just
about the money it's not because we want
to make sure that people know that they
should drink the right brand of bourbon
um that's not why it's just for the
money for the money for the state and
for the jobs that it creates and
anything
else I think that I only see three
people and I might be wrong who were in
the
legislature when when um under Governor
uh well Governor
hasson's interest in this issue um uh we
created an
Enterprise
operation and there was only one reason
to create an Enterprise operation it
wasn't to make sure that people were
drinking safely it wasn't to make sure
that rules were followed it was to
generate money and the idea was that if
the Liquor Commission was free of the
normal restrictions that a state agency
has to follow they would be able to rake
in enormous amounts of money I was never
particularly comfortable with that
approach but that's the approach that we
took and if you look every
year at at the reports of what has come
in and what has gone out you will find
that that initial assumption has been
proven to be incorrect we are spending
more and more money and we are
generating less and less Revenue so if
the reason for us to be in the business
is in order to get more money for the
state we made a bad
choice the reason I'm a co-sponsor of
this
bill excuse is not because I think we
ought to
privatize um although there are people
who are knowledgeable and think we will
get a onetime only1
billion
Revenue excuse me I'm not ready for the
legislative session
obviously um and this is a term when
we're going to need that $1 billion but
I don't think we should privatize seems
to me there three choices we can keep
things as they are we can privatize or
we can return to the days when the
liquor operation of the state was part
of state government and we could control
it that way we could see what was being
spent and how decisions were being made
and we can't do that now so with three
choices privatize keep things as they
are or bring three obvious choices and
bring um liquor back under the umbrella
of the state it seems to me that the
third choice is the one that I would
prefer but I recognize that there might
be a fourth or a fifth choice and I also
recognize um that there are a lot of
variables all I can say today is we are
not doing what we are supposed to be
doing Visa liquor
because we are not using the state
involvement in selling liquor to provide
the funds that we need for the rest of
government to function and if we're not
doing that then why are we doing it at
all because I don't think we really want
to be in the liquor business do we um
well maybe some of you do but I think
probably not we like the money right I
agree with that Mr Mr chairman and I
know you and I agree on that completely
my point is we're not getting the money
that have been promised and in that case
I think we need a new contract why would
we stay in an arrangement that is not
generating the revenue that we need in
proportion to the money that's coming
into the Liquor Commission and I think
we ought to figure out why and if we can
come up with a better alternative it
seems to me we have an obligation to our
constituents and to our responsibility
to the state budget to make sure we are
getting as much for our buck as we
can and I think we have demonstrated
over the years that that is not what's
happening we're getting less and less
and um I hope that this committee
recognizing that there's no reason for
us to be in the liquor business except
for Revenue to the state not to The
Liquor Commission but to the state that
we would then support this bill so I
don't agree with the with the uh Prime
sponsor but I do agree that a commission
fairly drawn with representation from
all the interesting parties might come
up with a better answer than we have
demonstrated up until now and as always
it's an honor to appear before you Mr
chairman the honor is all all mine to
have you here visiting us oh that's so
kind of you to say I'm not sure I
believe that but it is really kind of
you to say we've known each other a very
long time that is true ref Sam Ammon
thank you Mr chair thank you for your
testimony
um is it fair to say that there these
concerns are are coming from the finance
committee it seems over the last few
years the finance committee has has come
here with different bills concerning the
Liquor Commission is this bill sort of
like does it
represent a contingency in the finance
committee in your opinion well um I'm
not sure that you know that I am not on
the finance committee I was on the
finance committee for many years that is
true but I am not on the finance
committee now I'm on the Judiciary
Committee however like you I am
interested not only in the matters that
come before the committee I serve on but
I'm interested in how the state is
governed and you can take the girl off
the finance committee but you can't take
Finance concerns out of the girl and I
look at the Liquor Commission and um Ru
the day that the state chose to give
up ordinary control of how liquor is
governed in this state on a false
premise that we would be rolling in
money as a result and um or at least
earning more money and that's why an
Enterprise operation was created and I
think we've proven that it's not it has
been proven that that's not quite
working out the way we had
hoped represent
spe uh seeing in the in the news that uh
the sale of liquor is down all over the
country really and and it was mentioned
worldwide
M uh the question of getting blood from
a Stone comes out but but what I'm
really concerned about is one of the
things I've seen in some of the results
of the commissions and I read everything
is that a premise that starts out is how
the commission ends up that is a
preconceived notion of how they want it
to go so commissions don't always come
out with valid results just as the idea
of not of making it an Enterprise did
not work
out um I'm wondering if and and I guess
the commission could decide if it was
being open totally open-minded that
maybe what we have to do is just
improving whatever the Liquor Commission
is doing I I don't know how that would
work out but I'm not I just don't I am
not clear the idea that a private
business runs better than a government
business that doesn't always wash
so I'm not clear
on
where a private business and maybe you
already agree that this may not be that
a private business would ever do
anything other than make the private
company make a lot of money and we the
state may not make a thing on it which
is what we more often see well I quite
agree with you what I said early on is
that I do not agree with the prime
sponsor that the answer is to privatize
I think if we're going to be in liquor
business we ought to bring it back under
the umbrella of state government that's
what I think is the but I also will say
that you're absolutely right I mean I
think of the Articles of Confederation
you know they were just going to make a
few changes and they did make a few
changes and now we have the Constitution
of the United States so we have no idea
what the commission is going to do and I
hope the commission might be better than
the rest of us who have been involved in
trying to solve this problem and come up
with a new idea a better way of doing it
I think that would be great I don't know
if that will happen or not I see three
obvious choices there might be more and
I think a good commission under good
leadership perhaps of chairman hun will
be very open-minded about this um uh
might come up with a really great idea
of how we can in fact use our limited
resources to benefit the state not to
benefit the Liquor Commission but to
benefit the state uh and I don't know
what the answer is if I knew what the
answer is I would file a bill and say
this is the answer I don't know that I
do know I don't agree that privatization
is the best way to go I don't know I'm
not looking behind me to see what the
prime sponsor's face looks like but
that's okay we'll still be
friends it's always
R representative M uh thank you
commissioner um and thank you for taking
question I haven't been around all that
long to understand what what you you
were just saying you know bring it back
to the state are you talking about the
fact that it once you had to buy all
your wine and liquor at a state store
and now we have retail stores that are
private businesses is that what you mean
by bringing it back um that's a good
question um representative mward I mean
is not the decisions that would be made
but the governance
of uh those people who are making the
decisions it might be that we've now
seen that being able to buy wine and
beer you can buy you can tell what I buy
and don't buy wine and beer in grocery
stores right yeah okay that's what I
thought um
uh excuse me
um it might be that
um with a
new management
approach um
that part of delivery of the product
might stay the same what I mean is that
before we took the Liquor Commission
outside of of state
agencies which happened when we created
an Enterprise
operation there was some degree of
control within state government of how
the Liquor Commission functioned and how
the money was spent and how the money
was accounted for and how decisions were
being made um and um so that's just one
alternative I'm not advocating for that
I'm not advocating certainly for the
privatization um I'm not opposing
keeping things as they are what I'm
saying is we have evidence that is in
controvertible that liquor sales as we
have known them in the state of are not
doing what we had expected they would do
and it's time to look at them and see if
we can do it better there are a lot of
ways of generating money for state
government some ways I wouldn't be
foolish enough to mention to let the
words fall from my lips but there are
other Alternatives let's say there are
no other Alternatives and in that case
we've got to look at what's available to
us under the uh the social construct
that we have in in the state and try to
to get as much money out of the stone as
we
can represent Sullivan thank you for
taking my question so you said the
basically this is all about money and
getting more money for the state I'm
curious if obviously you believe that
but is that really what all we're
looking at because you could certainly
make an argument that there are other
things that matter like the service to
communities that may be underserved you
know thinking up where I live in the
northern part of the State uh I had some
friends visiting and we were in a town
and they wanted to go get a bottle of
vodka that night and we had to drive
over half hour to go do that from where
we were at that time and so I wonder
if if judging things simply on revenue
for the state is the most appropriate
when maybe uh in a a larger City it's
it's not a big deal but in a more rural
area if you have to drive through
several towns to just get a bottle of of
vodka um I there's another metric by
which maybe we should be judging things
on well that might very well be but I'm
not sure that um and I I'm quite
sympathetic not only just truthfully in
terms of vodka I'm also sympathetic in
terms of grocery stores and other retail
outlets that aren't as available in
rural areas as they should be and there
economic discrimination factors that
come into to play here and Geographic
discrimination
factors there's nothing that says that
any
alternative would or wouldn't address
your concern the reason the state is
involved is to generate
revenue and it is that
concern that I you know that that I face
it's not as if we govern in any way you
know who drinks and who doesn't um in
states where the state isn't involved in
this way you know people are carded
actually I was carded the other day in a
drug store and I thought that was really
pretty funny I mean you know really I
was buying something for this cough and
I was CED I that was interesting and I
was told if they got caught not carding
me they'd be in trouble I said at any
age they said well
65 and I said yeah but I'm
83 um anyway my point is there'll be
certain certain checks that take place
whoever owns and operates a liquor
stores the purpose is to generate
revenue and we ought to make sure we're
getting the most that we can get as long
as we're not willing to open up
ourselves to other opportunities for how
we're going to I don't know how many of
you watched what happened yesterday in
um ways and means when the
wonderful um Michael Kaine who's our
legislative budget assistant talked
about the shortage of available funds in
the current fiscal year forget about
what's going to happen in the next two
fiscal years we have a problem and I
think we ought to figure out how we can
get as much as we can to make the state
able to meet the needs of all the
citizens in the state whether they're in
big cities or towns or all the way up on
the northern
border um uh it's up to you you know I
we always enjoy your
thoughts oh Mr chairman that is lovely
you I was interested that one of your
members referred to you as commissioner
and I wondered if got confused in your
title we we I am a chairman and
fortunately the they don't have a
commissioner they also have a chairman
so we do say hello to each other as Mr
chairman okay
ref
uh I did it again didn't I sorry thank
you Mr chairman thanks for a question
well I I guess uh based on what you
spoke so far looks like from a business
perspective yeah I mean the only
objective is to get as much S as
possible as money Revenue as possible
but uh have you thought about the social
implications of uh liquor cells have you
do you give any importance to that at
all in your decisions representative
that is a very sensitive question that
you've asked and I'm glad that you asked
it I think all of us
are concerned about appropriate use of
um of alcohol of cigarettes of drugs of
I don't want to mention it but of do I
say cannabis or marijuana which is the
more appropriate term Mr chair we do
refer it as cannabis here okay then I
want to refer to it the way you do all
of that is absolutely important and
there's no question about it but I'm
here before the Commerce Committee I'm
not here before um the health committee
and
um we're here because selling liquor is
a business that is important to the
state and um nothing that we're talking
about here has to do with our own social
responsibility which is a very real
responsibility but the other thing I do
want to mention is when I first joined
the legislature before most of you were
born um not all but most I'm looking
around maybe that's not true actually in
this committee but pretty close
um we were we were a Libertarian State
and in the classic use of the word
libertarian which meant we wanted people
to be able to live their own lives
without interference of the state and I
was very comfortable with that I had no
problem even though at that point
basically since Adam and Eve there had
never been a democratic majority in the
house um and it was a number of years
before finally there was um but the
social
responsibility hasn't changed I think we
do have responsibility to ourselves and
our community that's how I've governed
my life that's not what this is about
this is about why do we have the current
structure of the Liquor Commission and
if we have it in order to generate as
much money as possible I think the time
has come
to get some people together who will
seriously say is there a better way to
do it and maybe there isn't let's let's
have that
conversation thank you fair enough thank
you thank you very much for asking the
question thank you it's always a
pleasure seeing you am I finished we are
thank you very much I hope you find
another opportunity to invite
me I think you made this opportunity
available to
okay chair will'll call on the other
chairman Joe mikica from the New
Hampshire Liquor Commission
thank you
Mr chairman members of the committee
good afternoon for the record I'm Joe
mikica chairman of the New Hampshire
Liquor Commission and with me is our CFO
Tina
deir uh we briefly will just we'll go
through the the packet but uh just
quickly because there has been some uh
questions on the sales of liquor and the
sales of cannabis I just want to briefly
give a few
uh historical little historical data on
it so as I had spoken in front of the
committee the other day for the first
time in 30 years in the United States uh
we're seeing a drop in alcohol so that's
a 30-year run of increase and since 2023
we're seeing a drop we uh a five a 2.9%
drop in
2023 an additional drop in 2024 of about
two two and a half% and uh closing out
in 2025 nationally they're uh the figure
from sip source is about
5.6% alcohol decline in the United
States over these those three years
after a 30-year increase and as far as
cannabis is concerned and again I'll
premise this by The Liquor Commission is
not pro or against cannabis but 44% of
the people over 21 in the United States
today are using cannabis on a daily
basis instead of
alcohol so on page two I'll show you the
17 control States and as uh the chairman
had brought up the last time we have a
note on the bottom that we have some
local
jurisdictions that are there with the uh
the dots in the states that uh are in uh
Alaska Maryland Minnesota and South
Dakota so 17 control states in the
United States and here in New England we
have Maine and Vermont uh we are the
only control state that controls the
sale of alcohol uh exclusively
Pennsylvania is our closest uh
counterpart and they have some State
stores and some private stores as
well so I'll move on to uh page three
some nabca which is the national Alcohol
Beverage Control Association which all
control states are a member of uh just
quickly we see that on the first bullet
revenue from uh the sale of alcohol in
control States the revenue is given to
local governments and M municipalities
and other important Endeavors here in
the Liquor Commission we not only Supply
the general fund with uh Revenue but we
also Supply HHS and uh with Revenue in
two additional sources which we'll get
into in the second in the in a few
seconds so uh bullets 2 three and four
are related to Public Safety control
systems that oversee retail sale
generally see a lower results in alcohol
density which means stores in the state
that serve alcohol the next bullet one
of the advantages control States is not
selling to underage people the our our
uh participation with the lenses is done
hand inand and with our stores as
well then you'll see a Level Playing
Field for competitive beverage
alcohol um we're here to protect our
communities from oversaturation of
alcohol and selling
locations the next bullet it benefits
producers which is uh instate producers
of alcohol Spirits wine then those
producers uh we approve the sales a lot
of companies will start in control
States and one of the success stories in
this state is Fabia lemonchello in Salem
Phil Phil mastriani he was unable to get
his product into an open state they're
not going to take it they won't take the
chance on an unknown product in the
control States we do that every day of
the week Brian from flag Hill is a is a
prime a prime person and could speak to
it but Phil from F breia has built his
business here starting in New Hampshire
because we gave the small guy a chance
an open State I owned licenses in two
other open States New Jersey and
Massachusetts they're not not going to
allow a small a small unknown person to
come into the business the way it would
happen in a control State and the last
piece is that we control the the
transportation of alcohol so the alcohol
is held in one warehouse in New
Hampshire we have our old Warehouse down
on store Street where we hold some of
the non-alcoholic products and some of
our one-time power buys but 94% 90 5% of
our product is held under one roof and
is done by one transporter to our
locations and those 62 or three
locations are all state controlled and
state run there's a reason why those are
set up the way that they are because
it's a control center for alcohol it's a
destination that people have to go to
and the the uh criteria of H buying
alcohol is governed more
Brickley on page three you'll see the
three-tier system on page four so I'm
sorry on page four and then on page five
you'll see the value of the Tre
three-tier system Financial Independence
functional Independence Revenue
collection and here's the key product
tracking we don't hear about counterfeit
or tainted alcohol in the United States
very rarely but in other countries it
happens all the time people are killed
on Vaca on vacations people die while
they're traveling why is that because a
controll jurisdiction takes control of
the product from the minute it enters
the state to the minute it's sold to
Consumers everything that goes through
those warehouses and through those
stores are products that we've
evaluated and our suppliers and our
Brokers have evaluated so in 2024 just
for some quick
statistics 1,200 people were affected by
tainted alcohol methanol contained
alcohol 400 are dead in The Last 5 Years
11,800 people have been affected by
tainted alcohol 4500 are dead the
control system clearly has its
advantages on page seven you'll see that
we we now have a, 10 employees 237 are
full-time 640 are part-time one of the
questions I've heard what happens to
those employees when a private person
Takes Over The Liquor Commission I can
tell you what happens I was a business
person in Private Industry for 30 years
those employees are let go that's the
bottom line and those those people that
take over those licenses whether it's
one person or whether it's 10 and I can
see seriously tell you it's not going to
be one because no one person is going to
come in and pay you a billion dollars or
whatever number it might be for your
business and then you're going to allow
them to have an open market so where's
the value and what they're buying if
they don't have
exclusivity there is no value in what
they're buying because they don't have
exclusivity you're opening it up
to stores on every corner stores you'll
be opening it up to a plethora of
alcohol being available to Consumers
around the state take a look at
Massachusetts our friendly open state to
the South and you can see what's going
to happen in New Hampshire you won't
have 62 or 65 locations you'll have
hundreds of locations where alcohol is
available now we have beer and wine
that's available in stores in the states
and we recognize that in the grocery
stores happen to do happy to do a
partnership with them
but as commissioner Earl Sweeney used to
say it's the difference between
firecrackers and dynamite that's the
difference you can see the breakdown of
the commission below the office of the
commission the division of enforcement
the division of administration and the
division of marketing and uh
merchandising and the corresponding
employees that go along with each this
commission is run very efficiently
uh with
237 full-time employees that's in the
store I'm sorry in the out well in the
outlets thank you Tina 340
371 employees with enforcement all of HQ
and in the stores we have augmented with
part-time for many many years as was the
request of the
legislature and on page nine uh Tina can
go through where the money goes
on page eight though you'll see that
it's just a breakdown of each of the
divisions responsibilities so you know
what each division
does so on page nine is just a five-year
net profit transfer history in the five
years we've transferred $
7792 million
6949 million to the general fund there
was
$29.6 that came from liquor operations
65.3 million came from beer operations
and we've transferred 52.7 million to
the alcohol Abuse Prevention and
treatment fund and 31.6 million to the
granted Advantage healthc Care trust
fund and since the Liquor Commission has
been in operation we've trans we've
produced
4.67 billion in revenue and since 2016
we've transferred 106 million to Health
and Human Services for those two other
funds
uh just quickly our our charitable
contributions and that's through our
Brokers and suppliers that's not funds
that comes out of the liquor fund to do
that our Brokers and suppliers sponsor
our wine events our Spirits events our
tasting events our all our learning
seminars and these are the state
nonprofits that have benefited from all
those events $4.3 million to nonprofits
since 5 and then some of the awards that
the Liquor Commission has won some
accolades that we've been given over
over the years the past years none more
important than being uh by state ways
magazine being the top control State or
the only control state in the top 10
five years in a row this business is run
properly with all due respect to uh
disagreeing
testimony so and the only other piece I
would add is uh
quickly if we are if this is something
that we're that we're going to look at
uh it was interesting to me in
establishing a study Commission of
privatizing the Liquor Commission that
we didn't have anybody on the committee
that was in the business
there's no one here from the New
Hampshire Brokers Association which are
private brokers in the state in the
state that employ people here in the
state hundreds of people I might add
there's no one here from the New
Hampshire Wine and Spirits Association
all of your private Wineries and
distilleries here in the state they're
not on the list and the New Hampshire
beer wholesalers Association again three
of the biggest four of the biggest
wholesalers in the state again employing
hundreds of people and obviously there's
no one here from the licker commission
so with that said I'd be happy to take
any questions anyone would have and
thank you for listening to my testimony
well thank you uh representative Herbert
has a
question your
mic and and thanks for that
uh
hello um thanks for uh that information
it was it was very good uh I I I
actually did the advertising for the
Liquor Commission for four years years
ago and we rolled out the wine uh effort
which was I hope uh profitable it's done
it's done very well thank you but the
thing uh uh my question to you
is uh does anything come to mind right
now while you're sitting that you would
like to take a look at on your own and
make some recommendations to where you
think we might be able to uh you know uh
have a higher profit margin or have more
sales or that kind sort of thing U and I
have a question what was the advertising
agency um portion how much in
advertising did you make in the last
couple years how much did we spend in
advertising uh the the contract has been
held by weedo uh out of Manchester for
several years and I believe the contract
is for a 5-year contract for a total of
$ 2.86 million 2.86 yeah I can find out
that exact it's 2.5 I'm sorry 2.5
annually okay that's that's good
information and U and I know there are
things you can do uh in terms of uh um
displays in terms of advertising in
terms of uh costs U prices you could you
could literally raise the prices on
alcohol if you wanted to or and or if
you needed to but uh um I I go back to
my original question and that is uh what
what would be number one for you in this
particular at this particular time well
when we met with Governor aot the other
day one of the things that I was asked
was to look through where we where she
thinks we could find some efficiency
and uh find some additional profits and
that's an exercise that we're going
through right now it's something that we
started about a year and a half ago and
I'd be happy to share that information
with the committee uh as as we take it
forward but the one of the biggest
things that we have to realize is this
isn't a New Hampshire thing this is a
nationwide and really a
worldwide uh Dynamic that's causing
alcohol and wine as well as alcohol to
sell less across the world there's been
thousands of hectar of wine of Vineyards
torn up in France there's been thousands
of hectares of Vineyards in South
America Australia New Zealand that are
being torn up because the cash crop of
of grapes isn't what it used to be and
we have a glut of wine and tanks in
California so the industry in general is
seeing a downturn that's due to a number
of reasons one of which is cannabis one
is W of which is the uh the health
benefits of wine or the not health
benefits of wine and spirits that we're
seeing uh the Surgeon General came out
the other day and said any amount of
alcohol causes cancer well that that
puts a little bit of scare in the
business and you'll see that suppliers
are concerned about it as well as
retailers and the other piece is the
Baby Boomers aging out of the market
that is a big segment of the alcohol
Market they grew up with alcohol in
their lives with their grandparents and
parents that's the that's those are the
people that covered they bought for
tomorrow the Gen Z the Gen X they they
don't buy for tomorrow they're different
they're buying patterns are different
they don't they don't stock in they
don't coverboard they buy better but
they don't buy as often so the the
differentiation is
huge um I have a thank you for that
information are you um didn't the state
at one
time do all the distribution of uh of
product and are you still doing that are
are the all the cars and trucks and and
those kinds of things the warehouse are
they state-owned and operated or is it
are they private uh vendors all of our
product is transferred from our
warehouse in Bow and we have a 20year
contct contract with DHL to do all of
the transportation of
alcohol to all of our stores and to the
lenses the the only piece of it that DHL
does not control is there's some private
vendors such as law law Logistics and
others that that distribute that product
to the lenses the market baskets
Hannafords and Shaws of the world but
all our product is brought into that
warehouse house from wherever it comes
from in the world from our suppliers and
Brokers is distributed by one company
DHL to our stores thanks for your
information thank you representative
miles thank you Mr chairman um thank you
for taking my question sure I first
would like to commend you on the safety
implementations with the product
tracking um that's very significant and
uh we appreciate that for the safety of
New Hampshire residents um I'd also like
to thank you for the extensive
charitable donations that you um provide
my one question is if the Liquor
Commission was to be privatized we would
clearly
lose a minimum of 371 full-time jobs
most likely wouldn't that also mean that
we would also lose all of those people
would lose their health insurance
benefits which are so valuable to our
New Hampshire residents they would
certainly lose their state health
insurance benefits thank which are
immensely valuable in fact as costly
sometimes or more than costly than the
salaries of those employees especially
the employees with
families representative
Sullivan thanks St for my question
and don't view this as me having an
opinion on this I'm actually just kind
of
curious if what you're saying is true
which I have no reason to believe it's
not with respect to the falling number
of alcohol sales we're doing Nationwide
worldwide sounds like
um I wonder
if if you guys or this commission or
somebody in the state needs to think
about what the future looks like
because it seems to me that you
generally want to sell a business
potentially that's what is on the table
here sort of when it's at its top you
know highest price you you know if
you're selling stock you sell it when
you think it's at its peak right um so
if that were something that were to be
ser iously considered um and right
now what you laid out sounded a bit dire
with respect to Falling revenues and and
patterns among gen ZZ Millennials all
that um
and you know cannabis taking away sales
the health concerns uh it it it seems
like I'd be curious if you guys have a
plan what you view the future to look
like and if if if it really does look
like the future is grim for this um is
is it appropriate to consider cashing
out for the state now while the value of
this business is as high as it perhaps
will ever be again I don't actually have
an opinion on what we should do I'm just
actually kind of curious about if
anybody's even thought about it in that
lens just based on the statistics you
laid out here which sound concerning to
me well I think like any industry uh
business goes through Trends you see you
see Trends in business it's a it's a
natural uh it's a natural evolution of
any business the trend now given that
you've had a business come into the
United States that is a brand new
business
unidentified as far as how how big it
can be or how far it can go in the
Cannabis business uh so that's certainly
of concern not only to New Hampshire but
to anyone in the alcohol business right
now uh there's a there's been a plan and
there has been a plan and one of the
reasons that we we uh reacted to this is
first and foremost in
20145 when governor Patrick changed the
license structure in Massachusetts to
allow for years and years and years you
could only hold three licenses in
Massachusetts when he changed the
license structure he went from three to
six to 9 and now it's up to 12 so one
individual in or one Corporation can
hold more than one license thus bringing
Total Wine the
largest uh beverage retailer they do uh
tobacco they do beer they do wine they
do spirits uh
267 stores in 23 States and they do
around six billion very disruptive to
the market they've been disruptive to
our Market but but we've countered that
by discounting deeper and the the the
biggest piece about it is we never
wanted to uh disappoint any of our
consumers so in order to keep our prices
low and to compete with Total Wine we've
discounted heavier we're now coming out
of that phase where we've kept our
consumers in place we're continuing to
Discount and you can see our ads in the
Boston Globe or on our website or any of
the social media posts we do we have
thousands hundreds of thousands of
followers in the social media platforms
so we continue to discount if we don't
recognize the competition then we're
going to be at a disadvantage every time
as far as selling the business I I
suppose at any point you can sell a
business if you want to uh if you if
you're to your point selling at your
Peak I still think we're at a peak we're
not at the peak of covid but we've we've
dropped off some but I if we had dropped
off some and it was exclusive to us or
even exclusive to New England I would
think I would be more concerned but it's
not it's a nationwide phenomenon and
it's a worldwide phenomena so I think
that you have to ride this wave out of
maybe not being as profitable but
keeping your consumers in place we've
clearly upgraded our locations 45 or so
so so of our locations had we not done
that prior to Total Wine coming to the
market we would have we would have been
devastated because protal wine stores
are 20,000 square feet plus they have
the shopping experience that we have
they have everything that we have we
have we have been blessed with the Press
worldwide and
Nationwide that say New Hampshire Liquor
Commission stores are the best are
either the best or some of the best in
the world and we're very proud of that
we've created a brand that people know
and respect and when your brand is known
and respected your suppliers and your
Brokers take notice and they want to do
business with you that is the goal they
want to supply you with product at the
best prices there one there's very few
things that I can guarantee you but if
you privatize the liquor Comm Mission
and you put stores in place prices in
the state of New Hampshire are going to
go up
exponentially and the 50% of the
business that comes from cross border
will disappear overnight I can guarantee
you
that sing thank you chair thanks for
taking my question I agree with you on
that because lots of my friends are
coming across the board order every
weekend to buy the liquor for the
discount my question is uh everybody is
basically talking about the efficiency
the productivity and the profit margins
are less so as compared to other states
who are selling the leaker where New
Hampshire stands and what's the ranking
in terms of Revenue as well as the
profit margin we have done any kind of
studies
or well we would sorry represent thank
you for the question it's it's one of
those things where a control State uh
margins are different than an open State
and we are our margins are tighter
because we of the states around us
Pennsylvania has 900 Plus stores some
are control some are open their margins
in some respects when I look at their
margins Nationwide we're we're higher in
margins than most of the states on the
Eastern SE
board it's hard to compare given that we
are also the the distributor you know
we're the three tier we multi- tiers
where if other states if you're
privatized you're only buying it from a
distributor you're buying from a
distributor so your wholesale price is
going to be higher than our wholesale
price and so just just quickly for the
record our GP runs around
29% and our net profit runs around 20
uh historically thank
you okay great thank you very much thank
you very much Mr chairman members of the
committee thank you for your time is
Dean the person you want me to
call Joe is Dean yeah yeah Dean
Williams who will give us a very
interesting perspective on this issue
yeah there we go thank you very much my
name is Dean Williams for the record I
live in Bedford New Hampshire I retired
from this business on May 31st of this
year after 40 years in the
business um it's a great business I've
enjoyed it I've watched what exactly was
your business beverage alcohol dur
martinetti companies is how it ended up
martinet okay and martinetti is still in
business it's just that I retired at at
the top of the
company and um you know when you when
you look around and go back through
history and see what this Liquor
Commission was 40 35 30 years
ago uh it is incredible that it has come
as far as it has come and to be as
businesslike as it can be um because it
wasn't in the beginning it was whoever
wanted to Fork out something to somebody
got something I hate to say it but
that's the way it was a long time ago um
it has changed and I only wanted to come
up here today to offer myself if you
have any questions about privatization I
also engineered and ran main beverage
company for 10 years from 2004 to
2014 one thing you have to understand
about selling this business it is a
legal
Monopoly you can't sell
it not as a not as one piece it you
cannot sell
it when Maine was looking for money back
in 2003 and 2004 that's what they wanted
to do they wanted to sell the liquor
business I had a friend who happened to
know the lawyer in the state of Maine
and those two people got together and
they realized that they were going down
a path that wasn't going to
work in their instance they needed money
they weren't looking to why the liquor
business was up or down they just wanted
money they they just had the hand out
they wanted money they were in a
desperate
position and we facilitated some
information that got them to look at
leasing the
business so that's pretty much what
happened there were four biders one of
them couldn't put up the money so there
were three biders in the end and we won
that contract and we ran that business
from 2004 to
2014 what we injected into that business
is what New Hampshire has had for a long
time now and that's a very
high-end professional
business we were able to bring that to
the state of Maine we took that business
over the 10 years from about 87 million
to just a little bit shy of 50
million the state realized that let me
back up a little bit they were the ones
that decided what the price would be so
it wasn't the fact of you bidding high
or low here's the price it was $125
million back then and what they said was
give us a revenue share what do you what
do you want what do you want to propose
as a revenue
share we came in as the highest uh we
won the bid it was challenged we won the
challenge we started the business on the
weekend of uh July 4th holiday uh
cleaning out a warehouse in Portland and
moving up to
Augusta that was the perfect opportunity
for a form of privatization it needed
help we Maine wasn't many years past
where you walked into a front room and
gave somebody a number and they walked
out back and got your bottle of Jack
Daniels and brought it out to you and
you paid that was the way the business
was done up there
clearly that is not the way New
Hampshire is and uh to um I was going to
call him Joe I'm supposed to call him Mr
Mika I guess um to hit to Mr mica's
Point
um it doesn't make sense you look at the
accolades you look at the money you look
at the growth over the
years you think of any business that you
know and if it a couple of years that
are that are challenging do you just
fold up the tan and go home no you all
get to work you all try to figure it out
I want to touch on the Enterprise as
well the Enterprise was a
situation that in simple terms allowed
them to run a
business I used to go around and promote
the Liquor Commission here in New
Hampshire just because I wanted to and
they asked me at a couple of store
openings and I would always say um
you
know imagine running a business with a
board of directors of
424 people on that board because that's
what this represents here is a board of
directors with 424 directors so the
Enterprise fund allowed them to get to
the point where they could make those
decisions you entrust them with a $850
million business you should entrust them
with the decisions to run that
so that's why the Enterprise I believe
is a is the perfect way and should
continue to run that way
um as a person who has run a privatized
control
State I can tell you right now and we've
had conversations in the past with some
of the legislators going back eight or
nine years and every time anything was
ever discussed or looked at it was New
Hampshire does not need to be
privatized you have one of the most
professionally run organizations in the
country out of the 17
States we were flying back and forth to
Washington because Washington wanted to
privatize it was going to be a little
bit different there were only two
companies that were vying for
it we were clearly going to be the
winner
Costco got involved and forced a public
referendum in that state and the
referendum was the week before the
announcements of who won the uh ability
to privatize and run that
state and what happened over those
ensuing 18 to 24 months after that
prices
tripled crime
doubled alcohol became a a you know
people just wanted it no matter what you
can't replace the
income and and figure out you know where
it's going to come from if you privatize
we're talking about 146 150 million
dollar right now annually going into
that general
fund if you just wrapped it all up in a
ball and gave it to the highest bidder
tomorrow and you got your billion
dollars or whatever somebody has
analyzed it to be worth
you still have to come up with $150
million a year add to the $150 a year
all of the employees that you've now put
out on the street where is that money
going to come
from it's not going to come out of the
air somebody said taxes can you imagine
taxing
somebody do you realize the beer tax has
been steady for 40 years or 50 years I
mean it hasn't it hasn't moved thanks to
this committee
thank you um I'm sorry I get up on a
soap box and I can rant and Rave I love
this business I love the New Hampshire
Liquor Commission um as I said I've been
through it from the from the beginning
um I've helped generate charitable
opportunities for the Liquor Commission
for our broker
organization uh I've been on the board
of a small group of Brokers the the
larger ones in the State uh so we're all
kind of in the same tempo and the same
step all the time that's a benefit to
the state everywhere you look this
operation is a great operation and I'll
end it
there thank you very much we appreciate
it thank
you chair we'll call in Joe
Ricky uh pin State I know that's a
distributor go what's
go also in opposition to the bill
how are you Joe Richie Pine state
beverage New Hampshire um I just felt
compelled to be here I live in New
Boston been in the state for over 35
years and you know saw this come up on
my email and my you know weekly updates
and felt compelled to show up and be
opposed to this conversation in general
um I'm very proud of everything the
state has done and what my company does
with the state they're World CL class
organization all my years prior to the
liquor business I was with Hanford
Supermarket so I came from the retail
world so I understand what they do day
to-day as a broker in the state um I
mean they're just topnotch I've worked
in Massachusetts Connecticut Rhode
Island they can't even compete with what
we do here so anyhow just wanted to be
heard well thank you very much for
coming up thank you Bob blazedale
representing New Hampshire state
employees Association in opposition I to
the
bill love this extra wide
seat um thank you Mr chairman for the
record my name is Bob blaz Dell um
senior lobbyist for the state employees
Association uh first off I want to um
state to the the sponsors of the bill um
represent lman I I'm certainly uh
grateful for his um work ethic and and
thoroughness to try and find new ways uh
to to fund our budget um certainly it's
challenging times and um certainly
appreciate his his interest in that
however the state employees um you know
I this is my 28th session I've I've seen
this movie
before um certainly have and I can tell
you that uh privatization just just
doesn't work
um and I think it's important to take a
look at I mean from our perspective um
selfishly state employees Association we
want this we want the state to be as
successful as possible when it comes to
revenues because that gives us and the
state the ability to negotiate really
good contracts for our employees those
who work for the state of New Hampshire
obviously the less Revenue uh makes
bargaining a little bit tougher so
that's that's our main interest and so
you know one one state to take a look at
is it's been referenced before is the
state of
Washington um so that that was
privatized uh back in
2011 and I just this afternoon um pulled
this up this is directly from the
Washington State Liquor uh control board
uh annual report from from
2011 and it states in 2011 their their
total income for gross liquor sales beer
taxes wine taxes liquor fees was 1
billion 6 million
$370,000 with an operating expenses of
$127
million uh net roughly about
878 uh 600 878
m650 fast forward um to obviously after
this state has been privatized for the
last 12 years um Washington state liquor
and cannabis board now notice they they
threw in the Cannabis board because now
they do cannabis um their 2024 annual
report for Spirit fees beer tax wine tax
liquor license fees comes to 265
million tremendous tremendous difference
so selfishly as representing all of our
wonderful state employees what I see is
we don't get we get the onetime shot of
that whatever the billion or whatever it
may be was but longterm which is what
we're all interested in um it's just
does not make sense from from a revenue
perspective you know in Washington state
if if you if you really drill down
you'll see three years after they
privatized um
93% of of the business was owned by two
national
companies okay in the first three years
in the first three years you had um you
had prices increase on a 750 ml um
15.5% um they have the highest liquor
tax in the entire
country at
$35.31 uh per gallon for for
Spirits so all signs pointing to
privatization do not look good from a
from a revenue
perspective um so costs do go up um
after Washington State privatized they
went from
332 locations to to to purchase alcohol
Skyrocket did to, 1600
um that's um that's a that's a lot of
locations which I don't have to tell you
uh the the extra additional cost that
that um that the state and the local
municipalities would would have to incur
after that um so um I would um encourage
you to to to vote this bill down uh for
all the reasons that I've seen um for
for many many years and just look at
Washington State it's a great model to
you know take a look at and get educated
in the privatization um happy to take on
any
questions representative spear this is
not really a question but you had a lot
of good information there is there any
chance you can email that to us it's all
up here yeah well that won't help no I
you know I I jotted down some notes um
I I'll do the best I can of course would
great
y okay thank you Bob all right thank
youum uh chair calling Kate
fry from new
Futures in opposition to the
bill good afternoon members of the
committee I know it's been a long day so
it'll be as brief as possible my name is
Kate fry I'm the vice president of
advocacy for new futures um we work on
um improving the health and wellness of
New Hampshire residents through policy
change um in particular my focus is on
substance misuse and preventing
strategies um on uh on preventing
substance misuse and the unintended harm
so I have some resources that I'll leave
for you today um and then I'll just say
a few words uh one of the things H it
was supposed to print out in nice colors
but it didn't um for I'm leaving with
you today cdc's um chart on proven
strategies to prevent excess alcohol use
and lower alcohol related harms um we
talked about two of them today enforcing
enforce enforcement of laws that
prohibit sell selling alcohol to uh
Youth and also avoid further
privatization of retail alcohol sales so
these having a privatized or com um
control State model is really the best
public health model as opposed to a
privatized model so I have this to leave
you um one other strategy is increasing
taxes but I guess we're not doing that
according to that last little
bit um I also want to uh talk a little
bit about I have um I do have some
information that be helpful um from the
national Alcohol Beverage Control
Association to really talk much more in
depth about what control control State
models do um for me it really isn't
about the money I'm not lying when I say
that it really is about public health
it's really about protection it's really
about
responsible um use of alcohol and we
really see as as Bob touched um based on
that public health um or control State
models really emulate that and so where
we see um well it's great we do see an
increase in Revenue in control models
what I'm happier about is the fact that
we see less
consumption and um less premises on-site
premises so when we talk about this
commission I hope that if it does go
forward and I'm not sure if it should
but if it does there's a lot of other
aspects to uh whether a State should be
having a control or um private model and
those are also having a lot to do uh
with public health and um being kind of
an expert on Al alcohol policy in the
state I would like new Futures to be on
that commission as well as the industry
because I think you need a balance but
at the same time I think we've also kind
of talked out uh reasons why um I don't
know if a a commission is the best use
of time so I will leave these resources
for you and I'm happy to address oh and
I had one more sorry um I'm sorry about
that the other thing that that uh New
Hampshire commission the division
enforcement is responsible for tobacco
sales compliance I talked about this
morning if the division of enforcement
goes away and we don't do that anymore
we will lose some federal funding for
substance misuse prevention um from the
sign our Amendment so I just want to
make sure that's on the radar as
well and now I'm done thank you very
much
I guess they're all questioned
out all right last card
Joe
R
laa representing the uh wine in spirits
broker Association thank you Mr in
opposition
good morning and good afternoon Mr
chairman thank you for recognizing me um
my name is Joel laaka I am here
representing the New Hampshire Wine and
Spirits Brokers Association that is an
association of a handful of Brokers here
that represents my company that I work
for called Republic National
Distributing Company Southern Wines and
Southern glazers Wine and Spirits Ms
Walker martinetti companies
and Ruby wines and
spirits
um our companies combined not I
represent r&c in just Main New Hampshire
Vermont company that I work for operates
in 38 States 17 control jurisdictions 21
open States Southern glazes is bigger um
and so on and so forth they represent
about $40 billion across the country in
wholesale
operation what I'm here to testify that
we support the New Hampshire Liquor
Commission we have a wonderful
partnership with them and in the word of
privatization and I know the bill isn't
just about privatization but um why
would you want to take money from the
state of New Hampshire and give it to a
private company private companies would
be happy to take the money but the New
Hampshire Liquor Commission operates in
a wonderful fashion best-in class and
all the control States runs met much
better than probably every private no
disrespect to private ret retailers but
they run a wonderful operation that's
world class it's recognized by national
outfits so we are proud to be a partner
with the state of New Hampshire with the
New Hampshire Liquor Commission as an
association as businesses for the record
I'm a lifer in New Hampshire 64 years
I'm second generation in this business
I'm a father I'm a grandfather taxpayer
on my life I've enjoyed the revenue that
Liquor Commission passes on to the state
of New Hamp for all these years as a
taxpayer and as a voter I appreciate it
very much and uh I am here to answer any
questions otherwise I'll try to be short
and brief and get out of your your hair
today so I do have a question um you
guys operate in Massachusetts also right
r&c does not I have maret is out Martin
Yeti does Ruby does Walker does and
Southern Glazer just bought Horizon my
former employer in Massachusetts few
weeks ago so does Total Wine gets its
its product through the instate
Massachusetts distributors or is it
getting it from from a national corre
they have to go through a wholesaler to
go through an instate whol everything
has to be cleared through an instate
wholesaler or distributor one way or
another yes interesting okay great thank
you thank you
all I have no more cards so I going to
close the hearing on this
bill and take a momentary breath until
we'll start the next
one
which hopefully will not have as many
proponents no I'm just saying it has
many proponents I was looking at you
yes I
but then I look down and realize you're
not on the
bill it's I I I would have just assume
this would have been your bill I would
just assume that Keith would be on
it and you would be on
it that's right you yeah
right yeah the yeah the removing the
requirement of on premise beverage
licenses serve
food right now I'm looking for a
sponsor is there any sponsor out in the
hall does anybody know this
representative
Hemingway from clont and is all I can
tell reming food
oh we can save ourselves a lot of work
because we're not going to do
this
um over the years over the years what
you usually would do is um is that you
we would just say tag you're it you get
up and introduce the bill and I always
thought that was stupid and a waste of
time I normally would say is okay well
somebody who is in
support of the
bill would like to
testify at this point I only got one
negative
card from the usual
suspect so
so in terms of of introducing the
introducing the bill I I'm I guess uh
representative S I just ask you just to
officially introduce it you don't have
to say you're for it you could say
something about how you've been down
this path
before and
uh that's all you have to
say well thank you Mr chair for that
honor of presenting this bill that's not
mine but as many in this room know I
would probably support because I am of
the mindset that we should be able to
have a little bit more freedom for our
businesses um I did try to do a similar
version of this this goes further than
what I preent or what I presented last
year although last year I because you
were so kind to me on a different bill I
I made a motion to um interim study my
bill which effectively killed it but
this bill looks like it would remove all
food requirements for selling alcohol so
for those of you who don't know on the
community there's a few new me new
people here in order to have alcohol
sales or license to sell alcohol at a
restaurant or bar actually no bars
because those are illegal in New
Hampshire um so any restaurant in New
Hampshire that wants to sell alcohol has
to sell food if you don't sell at least
$75,000 in food you have to get at least
50% of your Revenue has to come from
food once you go over 50 or $75,000 then
it doesn't the percentages go away so
this is stripping that requirement for
for any restaurant that sells alcohol uh
in the state of New Hampshire um my
guess
is there's only one person on here I'm
guessing maybe it's perhaps it's a new
State Rep and maybe that's why he's not
here he is a first Tim yeah so this is
probably like a new experience as it was
for me last term um but yeah so that's
that's what this build does I like the
idea in principle and I will take
questions since
I'm The
Unofficial expert
would you believe would you believe
would you believe I would when I lived
in New York I lived uh for the first 25
years of my life between two bars cuz
New York has bars and every
weekend because there was no food served
in those bars every weekend every
windows were smashed all along the block
my my little apartment the building that
I was in was just they peed in the foyer
for God's sakes there's no way we should
do anything like this would you believe
well I I would believe would you believe
that when I lived in Chicago I live next
to a bar that did not sell food and I
saw no broken windows the entire time I
lived there would you believe two
antidotes that contradict each other two
bars representative wal do you have a
question I do thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking my question on something
that isn't your bill but just pondering
uh the possibilities of this bill could
it be possible to allow this at bars but
allow people to perhaps bring food bring
their own food to alleviate that problem
of broken windows as in New York I think
that that's a interesting thing that we
should explore particularly if the the
actual sponsor comes back to maybe our
working committee or something we could
talk to him about it cuz I actually
think that's a pretty good
idea you know full disclosure we talked
about this a little bit earlier and I
was in South
Dakota uh a couple summers ago visiting
one of my best friends who lives there
and we went to a place that only served
beer and and they didn't have food and
we were able to bring our own food so it
was actually a good way to kind of
accommodate that versus Banning outside
food um I think the next person who will
testify will help clarify that issue for
you Mr chair oh we have more okay does
this uh Bill uh impact private
clubs well I'm not an expert on this
bill but I don't think so because I
believe it's just going after
restaurants from the way I read it and
there are different things in here that
talk about hotel full service and
different areas but the all the strike
out language looks like it's only going
to be going after restaurants that
currently are required by these things I
think clubs have different rules and
regulations so I don't think it would
affect them but again I've had this bill
as long as all of you so I don't know if
I know I would say they have a different
license they have a different license
they have a different kind of license so
no it would not affect them anyways
right because I mean vfw's they
occasionally have food right and they
even smoke in there too uh maybe they do
but uh East Side Club the Manchester has
a bunch of private clubs and they are
active yeah it's on my bill I don't know
if if his intention was to go after
those but I doubt it would in back them
from how I read it no they would not
affect them because it's a different
license they're not on on on premise
license representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair um and thank
you representative Sullivan for taking
on something that you uh had no notice
of um but in regard to bringing your own
food into a bar um would you believe
that in Massachusetts there are
establishments or at least have been
establishments that sold beer wine and
liquor and food up to a certain hour and
then after a certain hour um and the one
I'm spec specifically remembering um it
was 8:30 p.m. they shut down the Food
Service
completely um and sold only beer wine
and liquor and at that point I tried to
bring a sandwich in so that I could eat
it with my glass of wine and I was told
that I couldn't eat my own sandwich in
in their establishment
because uh Health regulations prohibited
it I I would believe that that's
Massachusetts and we don't want to mess
up M so we will do a better we will do a
better bill that would not do that give
us more freedom so so just so you know
just so you understand that in New
Hampshire it is true we don't have a bar
we don't have anything that licens a bar
however uh a establishment that is a on
premise license C is permitted to have a
cocktail
lounge and that cocktail lounge after
it's 9:00 right yeah it's 9 o' is the is
our our Midnight Hour or I should say
our our beginning hour our Cinderella
hour begins and at 9:00 that restaurant
does not need to serve food anymore it
can serve you just
alcohol the interesting thing is that is
a higher liquor license and
Applebees because evidently according to
the former Chief told me is you ever go
in the kitchen it's just walls and walls
of microwaves where they they Grill the
you grill your steak but everything else
is microwaved uh they keep the kitchen
open the whole time so they actually get
a cheaper liquor license simply because
they don't close the establishment I ask
a follow-up question yes um and I guess
I'm actually asking this of you Mr
chairman since you brought it up um the
cocktail lounge um is the cocktail
lounge allowed to allow the customer to
bring food into the cocktail lounge
after 900 p.m. there is no law they
would say they can't but in terms of
maybe the health code of their Town
might have an issue with it but um I
have noticed that some establishments
have a sign that says you can't bring
your own food you when you come in here
the you know and I I assume they didn't
want somebody to stop at McDonald's and
then and then come in and eat and drink
at the same time but um again that would
be up to the actual establishment to say
you can't bring your own food because we
have always talked about with the Nanos
and the uh beverage manufacturers was
that yeah we we were urging people
actually it was the cigar bars we talked
about how the cigar bars is that people
should order pizza and have the pizza
delivered and uh and that was a
permitted use in under our statue and I
would say in the in the bar where I saw
no broken windows where I lived in
Chicago you people ordered pizza all the
time like you they would actually come
by take orders and then come back half
hour later or you just call in the app
or have door Dash deliver food so it was
quite common there so uh it's certainly
not an unprecedented thing in this
country to have such a a
model I have a question representative
spear that's another
question so no broken windows now in
Chicago uh I'm assuming they have public
transportation so if you do get
snockered you get on a bus or you get on
a Subway in New Hampshire we have very
little public transportation so do we
know that if we have bars and who knows
how many we're going to have how many
more DUIs are we going to
have I mean I obviously don't know that
but um would you believe we would have
more I wouldn't know but I would I would
imagine just like in Chicago or Boston
or New York um at least in the larger
cities of New Hampshire there's a lot of
uber even in places like like um North
Conway and stuff you can get is second
largest city in the state and we have
next to no public transportation no no
I'm saying Ubers Ubers so like I mean
tax you got a taxi comp tax tax have you
been in that
tax I can't speak to the quality of your
taxis you all done with
me does anybody have more important
questions good I would say that uh uh
when I was in prep school and I did get
to drink but I turned 18 and which I was
still in I was in in still in school but
the school rule was that the only place
we were allowed to drink was down at the
Deerfield Inn because that was right on
campus uh but that's fine but we we we
definitely didn't want to necessarily
drink there and we would go into
Greenfield Massachusetts and yes we went
to find that hole in the
wall beer you know know the terms of the
cocktail Lounge whatever and they there
was only it was maybe it was an 8 oz cup
but it was 50 cents a beer and and and
we also thought we knew there'd be no
teacher would walk in into that bar so
that's why we are very felt sa that we
can have all the beer we want and we
were drinking legally but but not terms
of the school rules okay uhair I have a
would you believe okay thank you Mr
chair uh I have a would you believe
there are bars in the state of New
Hampshire they are licensed to clubs
like the VFW the American Legion and the
DAV they do not require food that's
correct they have a separate liquor
license yes they we will learn a little
bit about that we have another bill
coming up about uh allowing uh getting
licensers for U barber shops beauticians
I don't know how far it goes but this is
would be a new license category for us
and have that conversations about how we
have such a long list of licensed
categories but uh one thing I can say
about these licensed categories is each
one of them has a little particular
rules to go with it so if you were a
tennis club you had to have two tennis
courts if you're pool tables you have to
have is it eight or 12 pool
tables 12 working that's the key word
that's right
the quarters so we all so we do have a
lot of other typ establishments um that
are are exempt from the food requirement
but they again are a unique
characteristic and um so we get to learn
about that this session which we have
not done in the last two years okay
um gief do you want to weigh in on this
one
or Deputy Chief's going to do
it we like tag teaming things again for
the
record uh Chief Mark armaganian liquor
enforcement licensing uh with me here
today deputy chief Danielle Elston of
the same entity
um one thing that we've spoke about over
the years and and in my time uh kind of
funny how the previous Bill talked about
Department of Safety and that's an
entity that I was part of for 28 years
um we always talk about burnoff rate of
alcohol when we talk about highway
safety and Community safety and and when
we do that we talk about the consumption
of food and in that consumption of food
you're you're creating an absorption
rate that difference differs when with
every one of us because of the
difference in metabolism rate or how we
metabolize alcohol um the average let's
call it an average rate of burnoff with
alcohol is 015 an hour so with with food
ingested in the system during the
consumption of alcohol or I'm sorry
consumption of yes consumption of
alcohol with food in the system that
food absorption rate into the blood is
slower it's kind of I I refer to it as a
coffee filter um when you remove that
piece from it you create a very high
absorption rate of alcohol uh we look at
rate of service now and and we get into
the negative effects that this could
create and the negative incidents that
this could create not only in a licensed
establishment um but out in the highways
out in your communities um we look at
this as a safety issue um uh Al alcohol
consumption and food consumption have
gone hand inand for quite a few years it
isn't it might be a old idea uh and an
old premise but at the same time it is
one that is very current um nothing has
changed uh in science to prove
elsewise um it is taught today in our
Academy and through our health centers
throughout the state so with that in
mind I I'd like to give the floor to
Danielle to talk about the technical
piece of this thank you I'll keep it
brief um as some of you know from
previous testimony in Prior years but
for the new representatives in the room
um title 13 is um very interwoven in
terms of Def definitions license
requirements administrative rules some
of the technical flaws with this bill as
is is it doesn't address um other
licensed types that also have food
requirements as well as definitions that
require the leny to have certain um
certain item involved to support the
food requirement so there's a lot that
would need to be addressed if food were
to be eliminated in terms of definitions
definitions types license types those
license requirements one for example is
this just eliminates it with restaurants
manufacturers however if they have a
tasting room or certain uh on- premise
requirements are also required to have
food so this would say that restaurants
can't have food but the manufacturers
have to keep a food requirement so
there's um it's not just as easy as
striking out um verbiage in one one
statute you have to look at it through
the definitions through the license
requirements and then also through the
administrative
rules in other words it's a whole new
small Snowball Effect uh cuz let alone
what do we have to do with off premise
licens food
requirements okay thank you we have one
card left and I won't bother looking for
Kate right you put
you okay you did sign in so but that
that's good that's all you need to do
but we knew you'd be opposed to the bill
anyways okay Mike you get the last
word yeah
y thank you Mr chairman uh members of
the committee for the record my name is
Mike Summers I'm the president CEO of
the New Hampshire lodging and Restaurant
Association nice to be with you all
again uh we have serious concerns with
this bill um I've testified on similar
initiatives I can't tell you how many
times in my 16 years but I will say that
uh there's a couple things but first and
foremost Our concern is that uh to the
Chairman's point we do not have bars in
New Hampshire we have restaurants and
they have very fine establishments all
of them um I will also say that um the
with Cocktail Lounges sure still
restaurants though let's be clear still
restaurants very fine establishments um
but I would also like to say that you
know the the obvious concern from the
existing restaurant ters in the state of
New Hampshire is that they have already
been required by Statute to invest in
all of the infrastructure that is
required to meet the food requirements
so they have bought uh you know hundreds
of thousands worth of kitchen equipment
and Hood systems and train staff and
refrigeration and freezers etc etc so uh
it would seem a little unfair to the
existing lenses who have gone through
all of this rig moral in order to meet
the current standards to then
essentially rip the rug out from under
them uh because now you could have bars
essentially on every corner with little
to no infrastructure requirement other
than some Refrigeration for cold beer so
uh that's obviously our biggest concern
and continues to be but I would also
Echo what the chief said you know we do
have a concern around safety to make
sure that you know uh we would want that
uh folks would be consuming food with
alcohol so that again uh mitigates that
real issue that can arise the one
question about Boo food we don't like
that either just be on the record
um we do not like that for a couple of
reasons one is that uh from the
standpoint of food licensing the real
issue for a lot of these businesses is
if somebody gets sick in their
establishment you own it whether they
brought the sandwich or not you're still
going to own that issue so um that's
going to be a problem from a liability
standpoint for us and more importantly I
think for the businesses is frankly we
would have lost a sandwich sale so I
think we would be more inclined to want
to sell you some food which is why most
businesses post please you can't bring
your own food in um on rare instances we
let you bring a birthday cake but we
draw the line at that so with that um I
would be happy to try to answer any
questions you may
have okay represented
Salin so one of the things you said is
that it's unfair because you have all
this infrastructure that's been invested
in by different companies right but
presumably they've only invested because
that's what the current Law requires
them to do but if it's in their best
interest not to do
it then
they could always switch out and get rid
of that stuff they could sell that stuff
if that's actually a more profitable
business model that they prefer to keep
if having a business that sells food
included or which is you know with all
this infrastructure that they need is
actually profitable and something they
want to continue to doing there's
nothing changing that so um like your
argument that it's unfair I'm a little
confused by
because they have the same rules it's
just that they came in and invested and
it is either is a profitable part of
their business or it isn't a profitable
part of their business and if this law
changed and say the the infrastructure
associated with that was actually losing
money for them but they were making
enough on alcohol sales they could just
can it all and still remain in business
so I don't know if the the fairness
makes sense to me because it seems to me
you make a business decision based on
the the rules the regulations if they
change you might pivot you might change
you might be happy about that change you
might be unhappy about that change but
um you know it seems to me I don't know
if that makes a lot of sense so let me
clarify unequivocally the food is not
profitable so the minute that you change
this requirement that business who now
has invested in not because you're not
talking about just equipment and staff
you're talking about entire remodel of
of an establishment right so you have an
entire corner of the building that is
square footage that's been given over to
a kitchen so you would have to remodel
that entire space if you wanted to
convert to a bar scenario but the real
challenge is if you didn't want to make
make that investment and now you're
operating as a restaurant and a place
opens up next door that doesn't have the
same rules right they don't have to have
a food requirement and they can now sell
their drinks for a buck cheaper per
drink all of their you know happy hour
customers Etc are just going to go next
door so now this business is no longer
profitable and ultimately more than
likely is going to fail and to your
point about making a switch you know
it's it's easy to kind of make a
Cavalier statement that they can just
switch their business model but
switching a business model at that level
is EXT extremely expensive and not
counting the numbers staff you would
probably ultimately end up laying off
and all the other bits and pieces of it
but you know we're talking about you
have to have a walk-in cooler you got to
have a walk-in freezer and all the hvc
support stuff that goes with that you
have to have an Anil Hood system uh
you've got friers and grills and and all
kinds of equipment so you're talking
literally hundreds of thousands um
probably half a million dollars in most
restaurants is just equipment in the
kitchen followup question right but his
point just make you sure you can't sell
a walk-in refrigerator well you can you
you won't sell it for a loss I mean I me
you won't sell for for a profit you can
sell you can s now you're economically
totally disadvantaged to that guy who
get I get the argument but you're saying
unequivocally selling food is never
makes money yes and I will put this out
as an example how many boo restaurants
are existing
today there's few and they don't last
very long and usually it's because yes
they're selling food and you're they're
bringing their bottle of whatever might
but usually that is correct right
because they're they're just trying to
get open so they have some cash flow to
survive and you have to understand our
business is cash flow if you're not
selling things you're not doing you're
not going anywhere so U but the the real
issue you telling me if they didn't sell
alcohol in this state then we wouldn't
have restaurants that's kind of the
argument you just made I mean there
there are a lot of restaurants that
don't sell sells for most of these
businesses that are in that space where
they are selling alcohol the business
model is bu on the on the understanding
that alcohol is the is the is the
profitable piece of their business so
what you're saying is that we should
just never change anything because
somebody's made Investments based on
arguably somebody here thinks this is an
inferior model that we currently have
but that whether that is or isn't is a
different argument but if I'm just
sharing with you that on behalf of the
businesses that I represent their
concern is that they have been required
by state law in order to have their
business that they were required to
invest call it a a million dollars for
argument sake just as a round number so
by requiring them to do that you are
then now going to basically steal 30 40
50% of their profitability in their
business and give it to somebody else
who's got almost no threshold to get
into the business does that make sense
no no I I get the argument I'm not sure
actually could you just hope give me a
I'll give you another example of it and
I was in think I understand it I was in
in
Montana and uh where I lived for seven
years
and I good then you'll know this story
firsthand so we went into the Mexican
restaurant and so I ordered a margarita
and she said um we well we can give you
a margarita but it doesn't have tequila
it's a a wine
based I go how do you how do you do a
margarita and a wine said well we put l
juice in the ger and I said so
so what was the story and what you why
you know why don't you have a regular
liquor license she said well it would
cost us
$250,000 and and I said oh you're one of
those Medallion States right and so
therefore the reason why Montana has
never changed their law is because
everyone of those people who spent the
$250,000 300,000 who knows what it is
now for that liquor license for that
full liquor license they will run down
to where's the state capital Helena and
say hell no do not change the law and
start saying anybody can get a that
liquor license so yes this is a problem
when states make laws that there is a
consequence going forward and I've
always said and liquor is a classic
example that you set the Press when you
eat pass something
you're setting the prent right this is
our version of The Medallion you get
people who now have an invested effort
to keep that law that you just passed so
you better do a good job of that law
when you passed it the first time which
just you know which is why I argue for a
lot of different bills over the years to
be changed or structured in certain ways
but on the on the Montana example and
kind of counter to his point
about food food not being profitable in
Montana there's a lot of as you know as
you clearly understand it's a medallion
State a lot of those bars sell food too
but then there are ones that don't so
I'm I'm thinking in New Hampshire we
could have a situation where both could
exist is just my point and and I was
actually going to get to the point of
Montana where I lived where both exist
and but yes they do have Medallion if
you just take right here in conquer
Tuckers does a great job serving
breakfast and lunch but they don't have
a liquor license they're not open for
dinner representative spear we heard a
lot in the last couple of days
especially from The Liquor Commission
today and last week about a big part of
their job is the safety and I can't
ignore that I mean coming from areas
where DUIs were horrendous coming from
areas where people peed in the Foy of my
apartment
building we cannot ignore the fact that
this is not just a financial
a financial decision that it's an
environment and so I I loved what the
Liquor Commission does and I like the
idea that people need to have a little
bit of food you don't have to order a
ton of food you can just have something
because you got to slow that stuff down
otherwise we're going to have all kinds
of problems that we're not considering
in the process of looking at this bill
would you believe would you believe okay
all right you don't have to respond to
no but if I could just couple of points
that I'd like to make from the
discussion that's happening so you know
if if if my comment about the alcohol is
not the most profitable part then how is
it that the most punitive part of your
statutes are suspensions of license
because that frankly is the biggest
thing that hurts
us you got to bring that up now didn't
we solve that last year to you really
what you still angry I'm still salty
about it but that's a different
discussion um but but to your point
could we could we have a scenario where
both survive we could but I think where
our industry right now with the existing
businesses the upheaval in the time for
that shift to take place we would lose a
lot of businesses in that space and I
think that's where these these are a lot
of people people that have spent you
know millions and millions of dollars
investing in their businesses are not
prepared to take the chance on what that
upheaval would look like and how long it
might take if that makes
sense representative pusc thank you Mr
chairman thank you Mike for taking my
question
uh it has to do with New Hampshire and
tourism of which the Restaurant
Association is a huge piece would
this not having to have uh food tarnish
the reputation of New Hampshire as a
family type place where you want to go
bring your kids in the summer and the
winter and the restaurants uh you'd have
bars but very few restaurants that would
be familyfriendly which is where tons of
money come out of thank
you thank you for the question
representative pusk
but after 9 it's all hell break well
it's an interesting question because
again I think there's also an argument
to be made that you need all kinds of
levels in the system right so you need
those kind of late night places for the
younger crowd and you need the you know
the breakfast and lunch places and I
think that I don't know that it would
tarnish our image necessarily but I I do
appreciate you raising the fact of how
important the rooms of meals taxes to
the state of New Hampshire and the good
work that all of our member businesses
do in raising that and collecting it on
your
behalf thank you Mike on that
thought uh well actually I was going to
say before thank you thank you Mike is
um uh I think that today was a great
experience for the four new members of
the committee to really get their feet
wet and the knowing about liquor laws
and uh and the Nuance of liquor
legislation
um I will also say that uh given that we
had no sponsor that um this is one of
the reasons why I never I I always
thought the idea that that committees
could kill a bill the same day they
heard it is a shame because the person
you know it should at least get another
opportunity to come in and and speak to
their bill um you will learn that this
is the only committee that that uh that
does everything by subcommittee um and I
do it because
uh I think it it really we want to show
anybody who who has a bill that comes to
this committee that they're going to get
a fair Shake we're going to really hear
them out um sometimes people will tune
in and say oh my God these people are
you know they're just going to kill that
thing so fast make your head spin but
but I think that it's important that we
have this conversation we have the time
and this is the reason why we that we
are a highly respected committee and I
think that also most important is that
by the time we come to an answer what
comes out of this committee um we're
pretty uniform uh in in support and that
and that's because we we give every Bill
its due diligence I've always said every
bill has a grain of truth to it sometime
that grain is so small I can barely see
it but it's there and um so I want to
thank you all for staying and through
this and uh we'll get to do uh so next
Wednesday I'm not going to do Thursday
I'm just going to Wednesday we'll have
um we'll do the liquor subcommittee and
then we have tomorrow we're going to be
doing the banking and their banking
bills so we'll uh do one in the morning
one in the afternoon I haven't figured
out which one I want to do but Wednesday
next week it'll be just Wednesday um I
do need everyone to uh decide what uh
committee subcommittee you want to be on
so for your new members the old members
I'm just going to stick you on the old
whatever you were on no don't do that
so you need to send me an email and let
me know what subcommittee you want the
one drawback is we will get the business
tomor you you haven't got the uh
insurance but I already know one person
who wants to be on insurance already um
and and uh but in terms of you other new
members just you know you you get you
now you've got a taste of Tomorrow you
might want to wait till tomorrow after
you hear all the business bills you can
have a taste of which which one you
rather do liquor or business uh and
insurance is uh is is a whole
another uh uh Byzantine system that we
have in this state that is much like
liquor in
banking yes representative gives uh
thank you um I'm sorry I missed the um
uh orientation meeting um but it looked
from the agenda as if there were going
to be more subcommittees than there were
during the last session no we have three
subcommittees uh liquor we have liquor
we have the business and we have
insurance okay so health insurance and
property and Cas is all insurance so
then I guess I'd like to stay on
insurance I assume so thank you all
right thank you all see you all tomorrow